هذه الدراسة أسميها دراسة مرعبة الصراحة
فلا يضيق صدرك في نهاية الدراسة
جات شركة «ناسا» وأخذت مجموعة من الأطفال في عمر خمس سنوات
قاست نسبة الإبداع لديهم
فوجدت أن نسبة الإبداع 98%
هذا الإبداع الفطري الطبيعي
جابوا نفس الأطفال في عمر عشر سنوات
قاسوا نسبة الإبداع لديهم فكانت 30%
كم تتوقع كانت نسبة الإبداع لدى منهم في عمر الواحد والثلاثين؟
5%
كم؟
2%
2% لا إله إلا الله
أهلًا، هذا فنجان من ثمانية
وأنا عبدالرحمن أبو مالح
فيه دراسة مذهلة أيش تقول؟
تقول: أن الإنسان يولد مبدعًا
فوجدوا أن الطفل اللي عمره خمس سنوات
تكون نسبة الإبداع عنده 98%
إذا دخل المدرسة وصار عمره عشر سنوات
تنقص نسبة الإبداع إلى 30%
ويستمر في هذه الحياة
ويستمر النقصان في قدرة الإنسان الإبداعية
إلى أن تصل في عمر الثلاثين إلى 2% بس
ليه الإنسان ينقص إبداعه؟
هذا سؤال، لكن السؤال المهم هو
هل الواحد يقدر يزيد من قدرته الإبداعية؟
ضيفي يقول: أن الإبداع والابتكار مهارة
وهي مهارة مطلوبة ومهمة للفرد والشركات
وهي الأكثر طلبًا للشركات في أنحاء العالم
وهي مهارة يمكن تطويرها
والسؤال الأهم كيف نقدر ننمي هذه المهارة بعد أن فقدناها؟
كيف نكون مبدعين؟
وكيف نقدر نبني بيئة إبداعية
تساعد الأفراد على الإبداع والابتكار والاختراع؟
أيش دور المدرسة والأب والأم، دور الشركات؟
كذلك وهو الدور الأهم
دور الحكومات في تهيئة البيئة الصحية للإبداع والابتكار
ضيفي في هذه الحلقة «باسم جفّال»
بحث و ارتحل لتعلم الابتكار في مدن وشركات كبيرة وعالمية
من كوريا الجنوبية شرقًا إلى ألمانيا وبريطانيا وأمريكا غربًا
اليوم يشغل منصب مدير الابتكار في شركة «علم» في السعودية
قبل أن نبدأ
هذه الحلقة جزء من حلقات رائعة ومؤثرة
في تصميم الحياة وزيادة فرص النجاح في الحياة المهنية والشخصية
بتكون في نشرة فنجان البريدية
روابط الحلقات ذات العلاقة وروابط الدورات
اللي تساعد في تنمية الإبداع وطريقة التفكير التصميمي
أما الآن، لنبدأ
متى دخلت في المجال ذا؟
ست أو سبع سنوات
سبع سنوات؟
تقريبًا
توقعتك من قديم، أيش اللي حصل؟
هذا المجال جديد أصلًا
أيش كانت نقطة التحول؟
والله شوف يا عبدالرحمن
تعرف اللي يحب الشيء، لكن ما هو عارف كيف يدخل فيه؟
هذا كان حالي مع الابتكار، أشوفه من بعيد
وفيه حب كذا سبحان الله عن بُعد
الين لاحت الفرصة
وأحيانًا سبحان الله بطريق الصدفة
كنت أنا أعمل على مشروع
وكنت مدير برنامج في ذاك الوقت على «حافز»
كان هناك مدير مشروع من جهة العميل
كان يجي واجتمعات دورية
فكنا نسولف مرة، هو يعرف أني أحب الابتكار وهو عنده نفس الحب
فكان يقول لي في شركة «آيديو»
طبعًا شركة «آيديو» في عالم الابتكار والتفكير التصميمي
مثل أبل في عالم التكنولوجيا، نجم ساطع
كان يقول: تدري أن شركة «آيديو»
بدأت تسوي برامج تدريبية على الابتكار؟
قلت: معقول؟ ما أدري
قال: إلا، فيه هناك موقع اسمه كذا كذا
وأنت تعرف الشركة من قبل؟
أنا أعرف الشركة مرة، أنا مغرم بالشركة هذه
ليه؟ اشرح لي عنها
شوف لأن هذه الشركة هي شركة مبتكرة جدًّا
هي التي ابتكرت أول فارة لأبل
هي تبتكر للشركات الكبيرة
هم يسمونها شركة تصميم
وهي الشركة التي تصمم الحلول الابتكارية
فهذول يصممون لقوقل، يصممون لأبل
يصممون لـ«ليفايس» و«لوفت هانزا» وكثير من الشركات
لكنهم في الخلف، يعرفهم من يعرف هذا القطاع
فيوم عرفت هذا؛ كنا مجتمعين فوق نزلت للمكتب
بحثت مباشرة وسجلت فيه أول دورة
كان عن موضوع «القيادة نحو الإبداع»
ولم أتردد كانت قيمة الدورة تقريبًا حوالي 400 دولار، مباشرةً
معليش أيش كان عنوانه؟
«القياد نحو الإبداع»
فسبحان الله دخلت في الدورة مدتها شهر
يوم مشينا في الدورة، فيه تمارين وفيه مناقشات وفيه مجموعات
عملية تعليمية كانت تفاعلية
ثم يوم انتهينا من الدورة
بعدها الظاهر بأسبوع أو أسبوعين
جاني بريد إلكتروني
أنا أعتقد أن ذلك البريد الإلكتروني غيّر حياتي
كان بريد إلكتروني من شركة «آيديو» يقول
احنا لاحظنا أنك من الطلاب المميزين
وقررنا أن نختار سبعة من أفضل الطلاب
نريدك أن تكون واحد منهم حتى تبدأ بالتدريب مع شركة «آيديو»
طبعًا بصراحة أنا لم أكن الأفضل بينهم
لكن أقول هذا توفيق الله عز وجل
أن تُختار كواحد من سبعة من العالم
كنت أنا الوحيد في الوطن العربي
هذا غيّر حياتي تمامًا
لأني من هذه اللحظة انتقلت من مكان إلى مكان مختلف تمامًا
من إدارة المشاريع الانضباطية
إلى الإبداع والابتكار الانضباطي والعشوائي في بعض الأحيان
وكذلك انتقلت إلى مجتمع جديد
يوم انتقلت إلى شركة «آيديو» كمدرب عن بُعد
تخيل نفسك عبدالرحمن انتقلت للعمل بشركة أبل عن بُعد
هي تقريب بنفس النظرة
فصرت موجود في المجتمع حقهم، دخلت في المجموعات حقتهم
صرت أناظر الطريقة اللي تتكلمون فيها
الطريقة اللي يتعاطون فيها مع المشكلات
الطريقة اللي يحفزون فيها بعضهم البعض
وفي ذاك المكان وجدت تأثير المجتمع المحيط فيك
حتى أني أذكر أثناء رحلتي في هذا المجتمع
أصابتني حالة ما أدري أيش أسميها
مثل حمّى، لكنها حمّى حميدة الحمدلله للتعلم
صرت سبحان الله من فضل الله عز وجل كأنني مجنون
أريد أن أتعلم عن الابتكار بأي شكل كان
فصرت أبحث وأقرأ
والمجتمع هذا كان يعطيك هذا
كانوا دائمًا يأتوك بخبراء والفريق دائمًا يحفز ومتعاون
كان عندنا بعض اللقاءات نناقش فيها ما يسمى عندهم
أيش هي مخاوفك وآمالك؟
أنا في البداية كنت أخاف، ما كنت أتكلم
أشارك على مضض
أيش اللي كان يخوفك؟
ما تعودت أن أتحدث بانفتاح عن مخاوفي وآمالي
أتحدث بيني وبين نفسي أو بيني وبين الأقربين
لكن في ذاك المكان يتكلمون ويسولفون عادي
وبعدين يقول لك
شلون نقدر نساعدك في تحقيق طموحاتك وآمالك وتخفيف مخاوفك؟
فوجدت أن هذا المجتمع مجتمع متعاقب
تكون مخاوف عملية وللا حياتية؟
أي نوع من المخاوف
فيه أشياء يقدرون يساعدونك فيها
مثلًا بعض الناس معنا من البرازيل
يقولون: أنا مخاوفي ما أعرف أن أتكلم الإنقليزية بشكل جيد
أنا كنت أستحي أقول هذا الكلام صراحة
أني لا أجيد الإنقليزية
يوم تجد نفسك في هذا المكان
لأن هم مقتنعين أن هذا كله يولِّد الإبداع
الخلاصة من هذا أنك إذا وضعت الناس في هذا المكان وفي هذه البيئة
يزيد عندهم الإبداع ويزيد الابتكار
ويصبح عندك فريق متكاتف ومندمج بشكل أكبر
طبعًا هناك بدأت رحلة التدريب
بدأت أدرب على القيادة نحو الإبداع
درّبت دكاترة جامعات ومدراء شركات وناس كثر من حول العالم
ثم كان عندهم المكافأة، ما يعطونك فلوس، يعطوني دورة أخرى
فكنت آخذ دورة أخرى
ثم بدأت بعدها أدرب على القصة المؤثرة
وأيضًا في هذه اللحظة وقعت في حب القصة
فبدأت أقرأ أكثر عن موضوع السرد القصصي
وشلون تبني القصة وشلون تستخدم القصة
وتوظفها في عالم المشاريع والأعمال
وبعدها بدأت أدرب على موضوع من الفكرة إلى التنفيذ
أيضًا مع «آيديو» واستمريت معهم لفترة طويلة
قرابة الثلاث أو أربع سنوات
هناك أنا أقول تغيّرت نوعًا ما شخصيتي وفلسفتي
فيما يخص النظر إلى عالم الأعمال
وتوظيف الابتكار للتأثير
وكيف يمكن أن نتبنى الابتكار في المجتمعات
والشركات التي نعمل فيها
والحمد لله، سبحان الله أنا أقول
أن أحيانًا تأتيك الأمور بطريق الصدفة
وأعتقد أنها توفيق من الله عز وجل
لولا أن ذاك الشخص جاء بتوفيق الله
وجلسنا ذاك المجلس؛ يمكن ما تغيرت حياتي إلى هذا الحد
الحمد لله رب العالمين
الحمد لله، كيف تشوفنا اليوم كمجتمع؟
مجتمع ابتكاري وللا مجتمع انضباطي؟
وللا مجتمع لا إلى هؤلاء ولا إلى هؤلاء؟
أنا أعتقد أننا مازلنا في البدايات
الابتكار في المملكة ما زال حديثًا في بداية الرحلة
في الغرب، أنا أذكر كنت كتبت مقال مؤخرًا
تخيل يا عبدالرحمن في عام 1960
كانوا يحاولون استنساخ تجربة «وادي السيلكون» في «نيوجيرسي»
احنا فين كنا في عام 1960؟
احنا لتّو نبدأ في هذه الرحلة
ولهذا أحيانًا المقارنات قد لا تكون منطقية
عندما تقارن نفسك بالآخرين
الآخرين سبقوك بمراحل، بدأوا مبكرين جدًّا جدًّا
اليوم أنا أرى أننا بدأنا نتحدث اللغة على الأقل
نسولف عن موضوع الإبداع والابتكار
بدأنا نرى ملامح الطريق
وهذا شيء جيد وتصدق هذا الأرقام
لو نظرت إلى ترتيب المملكة في مقياس العالمي للابتكار
تجد أنه في تطور، بل في تطور كبير
أيش يعتمد عليه المقياس العالمي هذا؟
يعتمد على كثير من الأمور
يعتمد على الإجراءات، السياسات، التسهيلات
الجامعات، مخرجات الجامعات وكثير من الأمور
اللي المفروض هذه المجموعة تدعم مخرجات ابتكارية
لما تقول بعض المرات: الابتكار والإبداع
هل هم مرادفين لبعض أو شيئين مختلفين؟
لا، هم مختلفين
مختلفين؟
طبعًا أنا ما أحب النقاشات الفلسفية
أنا شوفت بالمناسبة ذاك اليوم لقطة من اللقاء حق الفلسفة
جميلة عجبتني، لكن لا زلت لا أحب الفلسفة
ليه؟ لأن أحيانًا يصير فيه نقاش فلسفي عن الإبداع والابتكار
أنا أعطيك من الآخر
لأن يمكن هدفي من هذا اللقاء
هو تبسيط المفاهيم للناس عامة
لا أخاطب فقط المتخصصين
الإبداع يختلف عن الابتكار
الإبداع بكل بساطة هو القدرة على توليد الأفكار الجديدة
فأنت اليوم مثلًا عبدالرحمن إذا جيت وقلت
يا جماعة نبغى نسوي مقدمة حلقات بودكاست فنجان بطريقة مختلفة
جلست مع الفريق حقك
تجد واحد ما شاء الله عليه منطلق، يعطيك فكرة تلو الفكرة
وواحد لا، عادي يصبر ويفكر كثير؛ ثم يعطيك فكرة
فالأول نسبة الإبداع عنده مرتفعة والثاني أقل
الغريب يا عبدالرحمن أن اليوم كل التقارير تبيّن وتوضح
أن الإبداع مهم جدًّا جدًّا للأفراد والشركات
لكن على أرض الواقع
لا تجد أن الناس تعطيه نفس الأهمية ونفس الاهتمام
على سبيل المثال منصة لينكدإن نشرت تقرير حول
ما هي أهم مهارة تبحث عنها الشركات؟
تعرف عندهم الوظائف وعندهم تعليم لينكدإن
وجدوا أن المهارة رقم واحد التي تبحث عنها الشركات هي الإبداع
مؤتمر الاقتصاد العالمي فيه تقرير نشر مؤخرًا
نشر تقرير عن مستقبل العمل من هنا إلى خمس سنوات
استعرض فيه سلسلة أو مجموعة من المهارات التي تحتاجها الشركات
المهارة رقم واحد هي التفكير الإبداعي
ما تعرفها صح؟ وما تدري
مبالغ فيه وللا؟
لا، مو مبالغ فيه
أنا أقولك ليه
اليوم احنا في عالم متسارع بشكل مجنون صحيح؟
صحيح
وليس ثمّة ثابت
والمعرفة اللي عندي اليوم قد تنتهي صلاحيتها بعد ستة أشهر
فالناس دائمًا تحتاج إلى أن تفكر بطريقة مختلفة
أن تنظر إلى الأمور من زوايا مختلفة
أن تنظر بعين جديدة، وهنا تحتاج الإبداع
أن تكون دائمًا متوقدًا بالأفكار الجديدة الخلّاقة
فمن منا لا يحتاج أن في كل فترة
أن يطلع بطريقة جديدة في العمل؟
يحل مشاكل معينة في العمل
اليوم إذا جيت توظف
وهذا كان في بعض الشركات الكبيرة
يقولون: أنا أهم شيء عندي، حتى قوقل
أهم شيء إذا جينا نوظف موظف جديد
هناك ميزتين أساسيتين لا بد أن تكون موجودة فيه
ثم نناظر الأشياء التقنية
أول شيء المرونة
الشيء الثاني القدرة على حل المشكلات
أنت ما تبغى توظّف واحد كل يوم والثاني يجيك بمشكلة
يا أخي حِل مشاكلك!
يستطيع أن يحل المشكلات إذا كانت عنده عقلية المبدع والمبتكر
وهذه نتكلم عنها بعد شوي
تذكرت للتّو، هناك باحث شهير اسمه «سير كين روبينسون»
عنده تيك توك شهير اسمه: هل المدارس تقتل الإبداع؟
تعرفه عبدالرحمن؟
أعرفه
قال في ذلك الحديث
الإبداع مهم في المدارس بأهمية القراءة والكتابة
ويجب أن يحتل المكان التي يستحقها
اليوم هذا ليس في...
طبعًا هو حتى يتحدث عن المدارس في الغرب
ومن قديم وهو يتكلم عنها
المقطع 2006
من قديم وهو يتكلم عنها
المشكلة موجودة وما زالت موجودة
ما تغيّرت؟
ما تغيّر شيء
فالإبداع شيء أساسي
ويدل عليه دراسة قامت بها الشركة «ناسا»
هذه الدراسة أسميها دراسة مرعبة الصراحة
فلا يضيق صدرك في نهاية الدراسة
لا، أنا ضايق صدري من قبل ما نبدأ، فما تفرق
جات شركة «ناسا» وأخذت مجموعة من الأطفال
في عمر خمس سنوات وقاست نسبة الإبداع لديهم
فوجدت أن نسبة الإبداع 98%
هذا عند اللي خمس سنوات
خمس سنوات، هذا الإبداع الفطري الطبيعي
ترى البشر خلقوا بفضل الله عز وجل مبدعين، سبحان الله
الطفل إذا عطيته مثلًا كرتون تجده يرسم عليه
يسوي فيه سيارة، طاقية، يسوي فيه أشياء كثيرة
هذه علامة على الإبداع
جابوا نفس الأطفال في عمر عشر سنوات
قاسوا نسبة الإبداع لديهم فكانت 30%
نفس الأطفال بعد خمس سنوات
نفس الأطفال بعد خمس سنوات صارت 30%
من 98% - 30%؟
من 98% - 30%
سبحان الله!
جابوا نفس الأطفال في عمر خمسة عشر سنة بعد خمسة سنوات
قاسوا نسبة الإبداع لديهم فكانت 12%
الحين في عمر الواحد وثلاثين، هذه كانت آخر قياس في الدراسة
كم تتوقع كانت نسبة الإبداع لدى منهم في عمر الواحد وثلاثين؟
5%؟
كم؟
5%
2%
2% لا إله إلا الله
يعني في عمر الأربعين يصير بالسالب
المشكلة أننا نحتاج الابداع في هذا العمر
في مهامنا، في عملنا؛ نحتاج إلى أن نكون مبدعين
لكن هذا هو واقع الحال، والأسباب كثيرة
لعل من أهمها أن الإنسان كلما تقدم في العمر قل عنده الفضول
كلما صار عنده خبرة أكثر؛ ركن إلى ما لديه من خبرة ومعرفة
ويظن أن هذا يكفيه، و ما يحتاج أن يعرف أكثر
ويستكشف أكثر ويشوف طرق مختلفة
أيضًا الإنسان كلما تقدم في السن تقل الأسئلة عنده
تجده يقول: خلاص أحيانًا ظروف البيئة المكان تخليك ما تسأل كثير
خليك ساكت وأمورك طيبة
تبدأ تسأل وتسولف؛ يقولون هذا مو فاهم
مع أن الأسئلة الغبية بعضها غيّر الدنيا
صحيح
فأضف إليها أن الإنسان يبدأ يخاف على سمعته أكثر
يقول: لو طلعت بهذه الفكرة؛ يقولون
أيش ذا الفكرة الشاطحة؟ هذا ما يستحي؟ هذا ما يخاف؟
بعض النقاشات أحيانًا عندما تعرض أفكارك للآخرين
قد تصطدم بطريقة تعاطيهم مع الأفكار
فهذا لا إراديًّا يجعل هناك حاجز بينك وبين عملية توليد الأفكار
ويصبح الإنسان خلاص متصالح مع ذاته
متصالح مع المكان الذي يعيش فيه
متصالح مع الواقع الذي يعمل فيه
وهنا يموت الإبداع
لكن الأخبار السارة: أن العلماء وجدوا أن الإبداع كالعضلة
صحيح أنها قد تضعف، لكن هناك تمارين لتقوية عضلات الإبداع
فيمكن لأي شخص بإذن الله أن يستعيد عضلة الإبداع لديه
من خلال مجموعة من التمارين
يمكن أن تزيد نسبة الإبداع لديه بما يزيد عن 70%
وهذه معروفة ومجرّبة، وكثير من الأبحاث أُجريت عليها
حتى لو كنت لكبير في السن؟
حتى لو كنت كبير في السن
عجيب والله
هل ممكن أن يكون نقص الإبداع سببه المدرسة؟
المدرسة تلقاها من أولى ابتدائي وحتى من تمهيدي
ما أعرف، ما لحقت تمهيدي
بس أن كلهم يعلمونك على أنك لازم تعرف الجواب اللي مكتوب لك
وأن هو الجواب الصحيح فقط
وأن الأسئلة الغبية المفترض أنك تحتفظ فيها لنفسك
صحيح
فالمدرسة وهي تشكلك بشكل أو بآخر
فهل هي السبب الأساسي؟
المدرسة هي من الأسباب الأساسية
كلنا نتخرج من المدارس
والمدارس مع الأسرة، مع المجتمع
هي تصقل شخصية الإنسان وتشكّلها
فالمدرسة التي لا تعطي مجال للناس
أنهم يتساءلون كما ينبغي
ولا تتقبل الأسئلة الغبية من الطلاب
وتُصر على أن ثمّة إجابة واحدة صحيحة
هذه مدرسة في الغالب تقتل الإبداع
هذا السواد الأعظم
اليوم في عالم الأعمال، احنا نعرف يا عبدالرحمن
أن ليس بالضرورة ثمّة إجابة واحدة صحيحة، صحيح؟
صحيح
في المدارس يعلموننا أنك لازم تجيب الإجابة الصحيحة
ويمكن هذه من أكبر مآخذ «كين روبينسون»
على نظام التعليم القائم اليوم
تخيل عبدالرحمن اليوم في أمريكا
هناك أكثر من 2 مليون طالب
يتسربون من التعليم الثانوي إلى الشارع، ليه؟
يقول لك: التعليم غير جاذب
اللي يجلسون 60% منهم غير مندمجين أصلًا في العملية التعليمية
طبعًا اللي يطلعون من المدارس
في الغالب يصبحون مصدر مشاكل في المجتمع
ولهذا تجد عندهم واحد تقريبًا من بين كل ثلاثين تشوفهم قدامك
هو أما موقوف أو طلع من السجن
أو عنده إقامة جبرية أو عنده مشكلة
وهؤلاء تخيل تكلفتهم في السجون
أكبر بكثير من تكلفتهم في التعليم
صحيح
فالعملية معقدة جدًّا
الذي كان يدعو إليه «كين روبينسون» أن تكون العملية التعليمية
تتمحور حول إيجاد حلول لمشكلات حقيقية يراها الطلاب حولهم
مشاريع يعملون عليها خلال السنة؛ يسلموها في نهاية السنة
يعملون كمجموعات
يرون ثمرة أعمالهم هذا على شيء حقيقي ملموس
ونفس هذا النموذج تراه متبع في سنقافورة
اليوم سنقافورة هي واحدة من أفضل دول العالم في التعليم
سنقافورة اليوم ترتيبها خمسة
هذه الدولة الصغيرة، خمسة في الترتيب العالمي للابتكار
تخيل هي تناطح الدول العظمى
سبب أساسي في نهضة سنقافورة هو النظام التعليمي المرن
أول شيء نظام تعليمي قد يتغير في أي لحظة، المحتوى
إذا وجدوا أن اليوم هناك توجه نحو الذكاء الاصطناعي واهتمام كبير
لا مشكلة في تغيير بعض المناهج
حتى تواكب التغيّر اللي جالس يصير في العالم
ويدربونهم كما ذكرت على أن الطالب يعمل على مشاريع
توجِد حلول إبداعية لمشكلات يراها حوله
وطُبقت مثل هذه التجارب في بعض المدارس في أمريكا
بناءً على مشاريع «كين روبينسون»
ووجد أن بعض الطلاب الذين كان تحصيلهم العلمي سيء
وكانوا غير مندمجين في العملية التعليمية
وجد أن مستوهم التعليمي ارتفع
وأصبحوا جدًّا مندمجين في العملية التعليمية
احنا متفائلين، لكن هناك الكثير من العمل
ما أدري على أيش تتفاءل الصدق
لأني أيش اللي بقوله
المناداة بتغيير التعليم قديمة
والتغيّرات اللي تصير في العالم أسرع من المطالبات أو حتى الوقت
ولا شيء تغيّر
فلا تزال اليوم نفس المواد ونفس الطريقة
ونفس المعلمين ونفس الحصص ونفس المدارس
هي نفسها اللي قبل خمسين سنة
صحيح
هذا الإشكال، لأن اللي يدرس الآن أولى ابتدائي هو بيتخرج 2040
اللي يدعوني للتفاؤل عبدالرحمن
أن هناك اليوم توجه من بعض الجهات
إلى دمج الابتكار ضمن المناهج التعليمية
هناك بعض المبادرات من بعض الجهات
أن يكون هناك مواد تعليمية تتكلم عن الابتكار، عن التفكير التصميمي
طبعًا قد لا يكون هذا كافي، لأنك تحتاج تغيير شامل
أتفق معك تمامًا
لكن أنا متفائل لأن على الأقل رأينا هذه الخطوة
هناك بعض الجامعات اليوم بدأت تدرّس
تعطي ماجستير في الذكاء الاصطناعي
وهذا شيء أيضًا مبشّر
خلني برجع لكم نقطة أنت قلتها
فودي أقفلها قبل ما ننتقل للفكرة الثانية
ما جاوبنا على الفرق بين الإبداع والابتكار
أحسنت، الابداع قلنا هو القدرة على توليد الأفكار الجديدة
الابتكار هو تحويل هذه الأفكار الجديدة إلى شيء ملموس ذو قيمة
طيب برأيك أيهما أصعب؟
الأول أتوقع، الإبداع أصعب
الأول؟ الأول سهل
والله؟
الحين نعطيك شوية تمارين تطلع من هنا مبدع جدًّا
أنت مبدع، لكن يزيد عندك يمكن بنسبة 60%
لكن الابتكار هو الصعب، ليه؟
لأن بعد فترة تجد أن الأفكار لديك كثيرة
لكن شلون تحوّل هذه الفكرة إلى شيء حقيقي وملموس وذو قيمة؟
لأن قد لا تكون كل الأفكار ذات قيمة
اليوم عدد الاختراعات كثير ومهول
90% منها بلا قيمة، لأنه غير قابل للتنفيذ
غير قابل للتنفيذ من ناحية أقصد
ما له قيمة ملموسة
إيه، قيمة اقتصادية ملموسة
فإنك تستطيع أن تحول هذه الأفكار إلى شيء ملموس ذو قيمة
هذه رحلة طويلة
ولهذا لو تناظر حتى الشركات الكبيرة عندنا
ترى ابتكاراتها قليلة، ليه؟
لأن الموضوع صعب ليس بتلك السهولة
لربما كل عشرين سنة ترى منتج كبير عند شركة أبل
لأن الموضوع صعب
لكن لا بد أنك تهيئ الظروف حتى تأتي هذه الفرصة
وإلا فلن تأتي
وأنا أذكر شركة أمازون حاولوا أن يدخلوا في سوق الجوالات
سووا «أمازون فاير» حتى ما نذكر وأحيانًا ننسى اسمه
كان فشل ذريع، لكن لأن أمازون شركة ابتكارية
تهيئ البيئة والمكان لمثل هذه الأفكار أن تخرج وتجرب وتُختبر
فشل «أمازون فاير» لكن نجح «أمازون برايم»
«أمازون برايم» اليوم شيء جنوني
تخيل عبدالرحمن في سنة واحدة
قيمة اشتراكات «أمازون برايم» 31 مليار
شيء جنوني
وبدأت بفكرة لم يكن يؤمن فيها أحد
لكنها وجدت المكان والبيئة اللي تسمح لهذه الفكرة
اللي في نظر الكثيرين أنها فكرة فاشلة
أنها تجرب وتُختبر
صبروا عليها فترة فوجدوا أن فيها فرصة كبيرة
سبحان الله نمت وكبرت
وصارت اليوم من أهم مصادر دخل أمازون
فهذا هو الابتكار
الإبداع مرةً أخرى...
تدري أحيانًا نجلس سنوات طويلة احنا ما نفرق
من بعيد نراها كلها سوى: الإبداع والابتكار
لكن هذه تحتاج إلى تمارين واهتمام
وهذه تحتاج إلى تمارين واهتمام، لهذا التفريق جيد
وأذكر واحد كان هناك بروفيسور في كلية «إنسياد» الفرنسية
دُعي إلى مشروع استشاري في إحدى الشركات الكندية
كان الموضوع عن التحول الرقمي
فقالوا له المدراء التنفيذيين: ترى عندنا مشكلة كبيرة
الرئيس الكبير في الشركة غير مؤمن بالتحول للرقمي
فلعلك تساعدنا في أن نقنعه
قال: تمام. كان هناك، عزمه على العشاء
وجاء جلس بجانب الرئيس التنفيذي
فبينما كانوا يتحدثون
قال: اقترب مني الرئيس التنفيذي، وسألني سؤال
قال: «نيثن» أيش هو التحول الرقمي؟ طبعًا بالانقليزي
قال: شرحت له أيش هو التحول الرقمي
قال: جينا من ثاني يوم جالس أسولف مع المدراء وكذا
يقولون: تدري؟ ترى الرئيس التنفيذي الظاهر غير رأيه
قال: شلون؟
قالوا: يا أخي والله يسأل عن المشروع ومهتم
ويبينا نكمل وجدًّا متحمس
فقال: وجدت أن مجرد توضيح المعنى يفرق كثير
لأن الناس كما نعرف أعداء ما تجهله
والناس أحيانًا يا عبدالرحمن تستحي أن تسأل عن الأشياء البسيطة
يقول: يستحيل أني أعرف أيش هو التفكير التصميمي يا أخي؟
الإبداع، أيش هو الإبداع؟
حتى الابتكار، فالناس أحيانًا عندما لا تسأل
وتتقبل أنها تجهل قد تعادي وهي لا تدري
وعندما يعادي يصبح سلوكه أحيانًا، وهو لا يدري
يدفع أي فكرة تخص هذا المجال أو هذا الموضوع
ولهذا إحدى الدراسات الدنماركية
وجدت أن مجرّد توضيح معنى الإبداع وكيف يعمل
تزيد من نسبة الإبداع لدى الناس بنسبة 28.5%
فأنت الحين عندك 28.5%
بس بمجرَّد أني عرفت
فهل تتوقع أن الحين واضح تشوف الإبداع؟
الحين الإبداع...
المفروض إذا الإنسان عرف أن الإبداع هو القدرة على توليد الأفكار
أجل أنا أقدر أكون مبدع
أقدر أناظر حولي من خلال بعض التمارين، نتكلم عنها
أقدر أني أبدع
فمجرّد شعورك أني أنا أستطيع
بعض الأحيان أنا أقول أخرج العملاق وهذا الكلام
أنت تستطيع
لكن مجرد شعورك أنك يمكن أن تكون مبدع
هذا يحفز مناطق في الدماغ لا إراديًّا
أن تبدأ بإذن الله بتوليد الأفكار
طيب، هل فيه شخص مبدع وشخص غير مبدع؟
لأنه يقول لك: أفكارك تختلف
فمو كل واحد أفكاره قابلة أنها تتحول لأي شيء
فمو كل إنسان مبدع
صحيح
هل هذه الفكرة صحيحة؟
هو الإنسان في الأصل مبدع
الإنسان في الأصل حسب الدراسة اللي تكلمنا عنها
في الأصل كل إنسان مبدع
والإبداع ليس بالضرورة إيجابي؟
والإبداع ليس بالضرورة إيجابي
هناك مجرمين مبدعين
فكل شخص مبدع
لكن تتفاوت نسبة الإبداع لدى الناس، هذه حقيقة
هناك بعض التمارين البسيطة يمكن أن يطبقها أي شخص
يريد أن يزيد وينمي عضلة الإبداع لديه
أولها: تدوين الأفكار الإبداعية
اشتري لك دفتر أو على الجوال
سمِّي الدفتر هذا دفتر الأفكار
كل يوم دون فيه عشر أفكار جديدة
أيّة عشر أفكار
شلون أحسن خدمة، شلون أصنع تجربة، شلون أبني منتج
في البيت، في أي مكان، أيّة عشرة أفكار
في نهاية الشهر بيكون عندك 300 فكرة
مجرّد أن ترى أنك طلعت 300 فكرة هذا يغيّر الكثير
في طريق تفكيرك وعقليتك
الشيء الثاني هناك تمرين بسيط اسمه ثلاثين دائرة
ارسم ثلاثين دائرة، أو تقدر تنزلها حتى من النت تطبعها
أعطي نفسك ثلاث دقائق
في كل دائرة من هذه الدوائر ارسم شكل مختلف
وناظر خلال أول ثلاث دقائق
أول مرة يمكن ما تعبي نص الثلاثين دائرة
ولا يمكن ثلثه. طبّق هذا التمرين مرة كل أسبوع
في وقت فراغك، ثلاث دقائق ما تضر
بعد فترة ستجد أنك بدأت تعبي الثلاثين دائرة وبأشكال مختلفة
وهذه علامة على زيادة الإبداع
أيضًا من الأمور التي تزيد الإبداع يقولون المشي
في دراسة لجامعة «ستانفورد»
وجدوا أن مستوى الإبداع لدى الناس أثناء المشي
وبعده بثلاثين دقيقة يزيد بنسبة 60%
ولهذا تذكر قبل فترة طلع ترند الاجتماعات وأنت ماشي
هذا واحد من أسبابها
أن نسبة الإبداع عند الناس أثناء المشي تكون أعلى منها
إذا كنا جالسين في قاعة اجتماعات
أيضًا من الأمور اللي تزيد الإبداع
حس الاستكشاف والفضول
حاول كل يوم أنك تسجل ثلاثة اكتشافات جديدة
أشياء شفتها في المكان، ما كنت تشوفها من قبل
هناك الكثير من الأشياء موجودة قدامنا، لكن ما نشوفها
فتنمية حس الاستكشاف والانتباه عندك يحفز الإبداع لديك
المبدعين عندهم فضول، عندهم قدرة على الانتباه
على الملاحظة، فحاول تمشي في الشارع
وأنا طبقت هذا التمرين
الحين الجو الحمد لله بدأ يزين؛ فتقدر تطلع وتمشي
كنت أناظر في بعض البنايات
يا أخي هذه من فين جات! ما كنت أشوفها من قبل
وهي موجودة طول عمرها في هذا المكان
فدونها، استمر على هذا
مثلًا هذا التمرين سوّيه مرتين في الأسبوع
اطلع واجمع ثلاث أشياء جديدة
المرحلة المتقدمة بعد الملاحظة
هي ملاحظة الأنماط، الأشياء التي تتكرر
على سبيل المثال
تبدأ تلاحظ أنه بين كل عمودين إنارة هناك ثلاث نخلات مثلًا
بين كل عمودين مثلًا أربعة مواقف للسيارات
تبدأ تشوف مثل هذه الأمور
لأن هذه مهمة القدرة على بناء الأنماط والانتباه لها
هذا مهم لأن في مراحل لاحقة، إذا جينا نتكلم عن الابتكار
تحليل سلوكيات الناس
يهمك فيها الأشياء اللي تتكرر، ما يهمك الأشياء الشاذة
فيصير دماغك يعرف يفرِّق بين الأمور اللي تتكرر يلحظها مباشرة
والأمور الفردية التي لا تريد أن تركز عليها
تبي نضيف حاجة إضافية؟
أنك تدخل الحمام بدون جوال
علشان كذا يقولون
تساعد في الإبداع
إلا كانوا يقولون: أن الأفكار أكثر ما تأتيك تحت الدش، صحيح؟
وفي دورة المياه
وللأسف، سلوك الناس تغيّر الحين
صار الجوال حتى في كل مكان
أنا ذاك اليوم في النادي أسبح وأشوف واحد من الشباب
جالس في المسبح ومعه الجوال
والله أنا بغيت أقول: يا أخي حط الجوال، أيش جالس تسوي؟!
سبحت قرابة العشرين شوط، وهو جالس ماسك الجوال
يتحرك بس شوية ويرجع، ومعه الجوال!
فالله المستعان
هو الطفش قائد للإبداع والتفكير كذا
فلما تقعد طفشان...
بس إذا جوالك في يدك طول الوقت؛ لا يمكن أنك تطفش
وإذا ما طفشت؛ ما يمديك تفكر في أفكار ما كنت تفكر فيها
أحسنت، الجوال نعمة عظيمة ومصيبة عظمى
صحيح
سيل المعلومات هذا ترى ما يفهم ذهنك
الذهن يحتاج إلى تفريغ
أما إذا جعلت نفسك كذا منفتح لكل شيء يأتيك
متى بتخلي مجال لفكرك، ولدماغك يفكر بالأشياء الجديدة؟
صحيح، حتى أحيانًا مثل طريق السفر
وحدة من الأشياء اللي تخليني أحب أسافر بر
فيه ناس تقدر تسوق وهي ماسكة جوال
بس إذا خليت الجوال على جنب
وما في شيء يشغلك، هي صحراء ممتدة
فتجلس توهجس وهذا الهواجيس أحسها ولّادة
بالضبط هذا مهم جدًّا
عاد وقت الفراغ، أنا عندي طقوس في الذهاب للدوام
تشوف زحمة الرياض الحين كيف صارت الأمور
أنت في المدينة الرقمية؟
أنا في المدينة الرقمية
آمنت بالله، الله يعينك والله
تبدّل؟ ترى مكانكم زين
المدينة الرقمية لا أحد يقرّب منها
الله المستعان
أنا أقول: الزحمة لربما تضاعفت ثلاث مرات خلال الثلاث سنوات
ولهذا يمكن إذا أردنا أن ننظر إلى جانب مشرق
إلى الجزء الممتلئ من هذا الكوب
يمديك تسوي أشياء في السيارة
لكن إذا كان الجوال هذا صار هو أداة الترفيه
ما تقدر تسوي شيء
فسبحان الله في الطريق عندي بعض الطقوس
تبدأ بوِّرد هذا ربع ساعة، ثم أشتري قهوة
لأن الطريق طويل يمديك تسوّي أشياء كثيرة
تخلص كتاب
الله المستعان، ثم أستمع لكتاب أو محاضرة أو دورة
وسبحان الله وجدت في هذا النفع عظيم جدًّا جدًّا
أهم شيء لا ينشغل...
لأني جلست فترة أنشغل في الجوال
وسبحان الله جاني ضيق عجيب
لأنك ما تحس نفسك سويت شيء
لكن إذا قدرت أنك تنظم هذا الوقت
اللي هو يعتبر وقت ميت ما تقدر تسوي فيه شيء
ففيه نفع عظيم جدًّا جدًّا
وتوفر على نفسك 500 ريال حقت المخالفة
صحيح
طيب أنت قلت أن الإبداع مهم للفرد وللشركة
أقدر أفهم الشركة، بس الفرد كيف؟
الفرد يمديه اليوم أن يجد مكان جيد في الشركة إذا كان مبدع
اليوم كل شخص تواجه مشكلات في عمله وفي حياته
فالشخص المبدع عنده القدرة على توليد حلول لهذه المشكلات
الشخص المبدع يأتي لمديره بأفكار جديدة في العمل
كل المدراء يريدون هؤلاء
بل حتى في البيت المرأة المبدعة
تستطيع أن تغيّر البيت وتسوي أشياء كثيرة داخل البيت
وتذكرت هناك امرأة ألمانية اسمها «ميليتا»
هذه ما شاء الله عليها راعية كيف
فكانت تتقهوى كل يوم الصباح
ولاحظت مشكلة في القهوة أنها ماهي صافية
يظل هناك بعض آثار القهوة
وهذا قديم تقريبًا عام 1908
فجات «ميليتا» وحاولت أن توجد حل للمشكلة
وهذا نأتي عليها، موضوع الابتكار
فابتكرت طريقة ألا وهي الفلتر
ثم ما شاء الله الظاهر كان عندها عقلية ريادية
سوّت شركة
اليوم شركة «ميليتا» فيها قرابة 5200 موظف
دخلها قرابة 2 مليار يورو في السنة
لكنها بدأت من مشكلة وعندها العقلية الإبداعية
استطاعت أن تستغل هذه المشكلة حتى تصنع شيء كبير جدًّا
وترى هذا اللي نحتاجه في الشركات وفي كل مكان
نحتاج إلى أن ننظر إلى المشاكل كفرص
وهذا هو التحدي الأكبر
لهذا احنا نقول...
بعض اللي كنا ندربهم في الشركة بالمناسبة
بعضهم سبحان الله كانوا بعيدين جدًّا عن هذا المجال، هو يظن
ما زلت أذكر كلمات واحد من الشباب يقول
أنا كنت طول عمري أظن أنني لا يمكن أن أصبح مبتكرًا
كنت أظن أن الابتكار هذا لناس معينين
ترى أنا كنت أظن هذا من قبل
يقول: كانت مشكلتي أن أنا انضباطي
وكنت أظن أن هذا الابتكار عشوائي ولا يناسبني
كان هذا في العرض الختامي لواحدة من البرامج التدريبية
يقول: أنا أمامكم اليوم ما زلت انضباطي، لكنني صرت مبتكر
وهذه المشكلة اللي حليتها، وهذا هو الابتكار اللي طلعت فيه
وهنا ينبغي التفريق يا عبدالرحمن بين الإبداع والابتكار
الإبداع مثل ما احنا جالسين نسولف هو أقرب للعشوائي
يعني تجيك فكرة تحت الدش، وأنت مسافر وكذا
تأتيك في أوقات يمكن أنت غير منتبه لها
لكن الابتكار في الغالب عملية منضبطة لها خطوات محددة
إذا اتبعتها في الغالب ستصل إلى حل ابتكاري
وهذا ما يسهّل العملية في الشركات وحتى على الأفراد
أن هناك منهجيات يمكن أن نتعلمها حتى نصبح مبتكرين
وهذه رسالتي لكل أحد
أنا أؤمن بأن كل شخص كما أنه وُلد مبدعًا
يمكن أن يعيد بناء على عضلة الإبداع ويمكن أن يصبح مبتكرًا
يمكن أن تصبح لديه الجرأة
حتى يحول هذه الأفكار إلى شيء ملموس ذو قيمة
طيب ليش دائمًا الإبداع يجي نقيضه الانضباط؟
شوف الإبداع يحتاج إلى أن تفكر بحرية
ولهذا احنا دائمًا نقول
في عملية توليد الأفكار هي مرحلتين
المرحلة الأولى، هي أن تفكر بحرية
بل احنا نشجع دائمًا الأفكار الغريبة والمجنونة
ثم بعدها تأتي مرحلة انضباطية
نحكّم فيها العقل والمنطق
ولهذا إذا حاولنا أن ندفع الناس إلى أن يكونوا دائمًا منضبطين
فلن تطلع معك هذه الأفكار
اللي قد تبدو أفكار غريبة في بادئ الأمر
لكنها قد تكون أفكار ابتكارية إلى أعلى حد
قبل أن أدخل في منهجية الابتكار وأثره على الأشياء
ودي أرجع إلى تأسيس الإنسان المبدع
إذا كان كل إنسان مبدع
عندنا المدرسة وتكلمنا عنها
واللي هي تكون عادة خارج إرادتك
مو كل الناس تقدر أنها...
«إيلون ماسك» مثلًا راح سوّى مدرسة خاصة لأولاده وأولاد الأصدقاء
فمو كل الناس عندهم هذه القدرة
فإذا سلّمنا بأن هناك مدرسة
يجي الجزء الثاني في حياة الإنسان اللي هو البيت
كيف يتعامل الوالدين مع الطفل
اللي يحاولون أن يبقوا ما يستطيعون من الإبداع فيه؟
جميل، أول شيء إعطاء الأطفال مساحة للتعبير
احنا وحدة من مشاكلنا أننا صرنا جدًّا مشغولين أو منشغلين
فأحيانًا احنا مشغولين حقيقة
لكن أحيانًا منشغلين بأشياء ما منها فائدة
فإعطاء الأولاد فسحة من الوقت
أنهم يسولفون ويعبرون عن أراءهم وأفكارهم
حتى وإن كانت في أغلب الأحيان أفكار
قد تكون بالنسبة للوالدين أفكار ما تسوى
لكن هذه نقطة مهمة
أعطيهم مساحة أنهم يعبرون عن أفكارهم
اصنع لهم مكانًا للرسم، للتلوين
وخصّص هذا المكان خليه جاهز
يسموه هذا مكان يدعو إلى ممارسة الرسم
لكن بدون ما تدعو الأطفال بشكل مباشر
فتهيئ لهم مكان، طاولة
احنا مشكلتنا نخاف على كل شيء
نخاف على العفش، نخاف على الأرضية
لا، حاول أنك تسوّي الاحتياطات اللازمة
وعطهم المكان ولبسهم اللبس اللي تبغاه
وخلهم يرسمون
احتفِ برسوماتهم، احتف بأي شيء يطلعونه
هذا ينمي الإبداع لديهم
وخله يطلع يشطح بعيد
في كل مرة ممكن تقوله شرايك تسوي لي شيء مختلف
ارسم لي الأرض من الفضاء
ارسم لي الحياة على وجه القمر
ارسم لي مثلًا الرياض في الليل أو في النهار
أشياء غريبة ومختلفة تخليه يطلع خارج المألوف
أيضًا اعمل لهم مسابقات
أنا واحدة من المسابقات المفضلة عندي
كيف نحل مشكلة ضياع الريموت حق التلفزيون
هذه مشكلة أزلية في كل مكان
تعالوا يا أولاد مين يقدر يحل هذه المشكلة؟
أعطيهم جائزة
وعطهم كذا مثلًا يومين، ثلاثة، أسبوع خلوهم ينشغلون فيها
وقول لهم: عادي تقدرون تبحثون في الإنترنت
تقدرون تستشيرون زملائكم وأصدقائكم
تقدرون تشتغلون كمجموعة
وهذه من الأشياء المهمة أيضًا
أننا نحفز عندهم العمل الجماعي
فالعمل الجماعي الإبداع والابتكار ينمو في الفريق
هذا يفكر بطريقة، وهذا يفكر بطريقة
احنا ما نبغى ناس في نفس الفريق كلهم يفكرون بنفس الطريقة
ولهذا يشجعوا الاختلاف بين الناس الذين يعملون في هذا المجال
أيضًا حاول أن تشوف لهم بعض الدورات التدريبية
أنا اشتغلت على مشروع
كان هدفه صناعة أطفال مبتكرين في مرحلة مبكرة
انا رأيت في الشركات المشكلة التي نعاني منها
عندما نحاول أن نغيّر في طريقة تفكير أناس في ذلك العمر
وجدت أنها عملية صعبة
لكن ماذا لو حاولنا أن نصنع طريقة التفكير هذه
عند الأطفال في مرحلة مبكرة
فصنعنا التفكير التصميمي للصغار من خلال قصة
الطفل يقرأ قصة أو يستمع لها
وعنده تمارين ومشاريع يستطيع أن يعمل عليها
يطبّق الشيء الذي تعلمه في هذه القصة
ونحاول أن نزرع فيه عقليات المبتكر
وسنتحدث عن عقليات المبتكر
لكن في هذه الظروف شيئًا فشيئًا
هناك ثمّة أنشطة من بعض الجهات تهتم بالموهوبين
نحاول أن ندمج أولادنا في هذه الأنشطة إن كانت هناك فرصة
مثل «موهبة»
مثل «موهبة» وغيرها
وهذا مجموعه بإذن الله يصنع منهم أطفال مبدعين
الجوال مشكلة كبيرة عند الصغار
الأجهزة اللوحية هذه تقتل الإبداع عند الصغار
لأن الطفل خلاص المخ يصير منساق حول ما يرى
هذا رأي وللا دراسات؟
هذا رأي ودراسات
اليوم، مدة الانتباه عند الأطفال تناقصت بشكل كبير سبب هذه الأجهزة
والإبداع يحتاج مثل ما ذكرت
أن الولد طفل يعطي نفسه فرصة وكذا
فإذا ما أبعدته عن هذه الأشياء
تجده أول ما يجلس في ذاك المكان الجميل
اللي أنت عديته للرسم وكذا
يجلس دقيقتين أو ثلاث دقائق، ويقول لك طفشت
صح
هو يبغى أيش؟ هو يبغى الجوال يبغى الآيباد
فتقنين هذا يساعد في هذا
تحدي والله
طيب أنت قلت الكلام، أحس أنه منطقية وصحيحة وكل شيء
سهل الكلام بس إلى متى؟
لأن هو بيجلس يسأل، إذا فتحت لنا باب النقاش والأسئلة
لكن إذا متى أنا أسمح له يسأل؟
أيش الأسئلة المسموحة؟
ترى ماهي بسهلة
هل أنا أجاوب حقيقة وللا ألعب عليه؟
فيه ناس تقول لا أنت ما تكذب، أنت تقول له الصدق
فهذا تحدي وللا؟
بالتأكيد تحدي، لا شك
يقولون: إنشاء طفل مميز يحتاج إلى جهد قرية كاملة
فما بالك في البيت؟!
هي عملية صعبة ومعقدة
وخصوصًا اليوم مع انشغال الأهل
الطفل لا يجد حتى الفرصة للسؤال
أنت اليوم منشغل بشلون أجاوبه
هو الطفل لا يجد الفرصة حتى للسؤال
فأنا أُفضّل أن نجيبه قدر الإمكان
قد تأتينا بعض الأسئلة؛ صراحة نحتار فيها، كيف نجيب عليها؟!
لكن نجيب قدر الإمكان والله المستعان
بس ما تقول له مثلًا: هذا سؤال خطأ
لا، ما تقول له هذا سؤال خطأ
ممكن تصرفه بس...
ممكن تصرفه، بس ما تقول له هذا السؤال خطأ
ترى سبحان الله الطفل مثل كبير
أنت لو جيت وقلت لواحد من الشباب
أو واحد قال لك كلمة؛ قد تظل في نفسك لسنوات
قد تستطيع أن تعبر عنها وتقول
أبغى أكلمك أو أعاقبك، لكن الصغير لا يستطيع
فتظل عنده لسنوات طويلة متأثر فيها وأنت وهو لا يدري
طيب الحين عندنا الجامعات ينطبق عليها ما ينطبق على للتعليم
ماهي بعيدة عن بعض
طبعًا الشركات، لو تسأل أي شركة
مافي ولا شركة أتوقع، إلا يمكن شركة وحدة
اللي بتقولك أن الإبداع مطلوب جدًّا
وأننا  نبغى ناس مبدعين وأننا حاضنة للإبداع وغيره
لكن طبيعة الحياة أنهم غير ذلك
فكيف الشركات تكون قادرة على صناعة بيئة إبداعية؟
جميل، سألت عن عظيم
في دراسة قامت فيها إحدى الشركات الاستشارية عام 2018
رصدت أكثر ألف شركة في العالم
إنفاقًا على موضوع البحث والتطوير
في تلك القائمة أنا راجعتها كلها
وجدت 147 شركة يابانية
كم شركة عربية تتوقع أن تكون في تلك القائمة؟
أتوقع صفر، ما أعرف والله
ما في حوافز للشركات العربية أنها تكون من هذه القائمة، صحيح؟
كان هناك شركة واحدة
أيش هي؟
شركة «سابك»
عجيب والله!
شركة «سابك» عندها مراكز أبحاث كبيرة في دول عدة
لكن صراحة تلك الدراسة صدمتني جدًّا جدًّا
أنا أدري أن احنا متأخرين
لكن ما كنت أعرف أن دولة صغيرة نسبيًّا مثل اليابان
عندها 147 شركة تستثمر بقوة في مجال البحث والتطوير
تسبق بمراحل كثيرة كل الدول العربية
هذا يمكن يعزز الكلام اللي أنت قلته
الشركات لا ترى أن الابتكار مهم
بل أنا يمكن أشوفها من منظور مختلف
أنا أرى أن كثير من الشركات اليوم ترى أن الابتكار مهم
لكن لا تعطيه الاهتمام الذي يستحقه
احنا دائمًا نقول: نحتاج إلى قادة مؤمنين
والإيمان قول وعمل
فاليوم لا أعتقد أن ثمّة قائد يقول لك
ما أبغى الابتكار هذا خرابيط
الكل يقول الابتكار جيد ونبغاه
لكن أين الأفعال التي تصدق هذه الأقوال؟
أنا أعتقد هنا الخلل
وأنا رأيت الخلل سببه الأساسي هو نقص الفهم لمفهوم الابتكار
كيف يعمل الابتكار في الشركة؟
أنا رأيت بعض الزملاء كانوا يجلسون معي
يقولون: يا أخي عندنا في المكان
جربوا الابتكار بضعة أشهر ولا ضبط
وقالوا: خلاص ما نبغاه
هم لا يدركون أن هذه هي طبيعة الابتكار
أنت اليوم يا عبدالرحمن، لو جينا قلنا
عندك ولد صغير طفل عمره ستة أشهر
وتقول: أبغاه يجري!
ترى ما راح يجري ما يجري الطفل ذو ستة أشهر
هذا مثل اللي يقولك أبغى الابتكار
يطلّع لي منتجات وخدمات في ستة أشهر
بالغالب ما يطلّع، ليه؟
هو مثل الطفل يحتاج إلى تغذية واهتمام ورعاية وحب وحنان
أنت تسوي هذا كله مع الطفل
لأنك مؤمن أن في يوم من الأيام هذا الطفل سيكبر إن شاء الله
وينمو وسيمشي وسينفعك إن شاء الله
تحتاج إلى نفس هذه العقيدة في الابتكار
ترى الابتكار يحتاج إلى وقت طويل جدًّا
وتحتاج إلى أن تبدأ في أشياء في نظر الجميع غير ملموسة
بل أحيانًا غير مفهومة
ألا وهي البيئة والثقافة
طيب أنا بالنسبة لي هذه من أكبر المعضلات
شلون تقنع قادة الشركات
أن الاستثمار في ثقافة الابتكار هو استثمار رابح؟
وأن المردود لن يأتي اليوم ولا غدًا
ولربما لا بعد سنة ولا سنتين، لكنه سيأتي إن شاء الله
يوم ضربنا مثال في «أمازون برايم»
لأنها بنت الثقافة والبيئة
سمحت هذه الثقافة والبيئة المبنية على حب التجريب
والتعلم وتقبل الفشل
سمحت لمثل هذه الأفكار أن تنمو وتجد طريقها
في الشركات اليوم نحتاج إلى بناء نفس الثقافة
الثقافة هي السلوكيات والمعتقدات بكل بساطة
فشلون نبني عند الموظفين المعتقدات التي يحتاجها الابتكار حتى ينمو؟
مثلًا احنا دائمًا نقول
الشخص المبتكر يجب أن يكون لديه العقلية
لا بد أن يؤمن أن الفكرة في أول أشكالها
في الغالب لن تكون ناضجة
بل ربما تكون فكرة سيئة، لكنها مع الوقت تتطور
وهذا يتطلب التجريب لفترات طويلة
بعض الشركات لا تطيق هذا
بل هناك دراسة أحيانًا تكون محبطة للبعض
لكن لا بأس خلنا نكون واقعيين
«أليكس» مبتكر مخطط نموذج العمل التجاري
يقول: أنت تحتاج إلى 250 تجربة
كل تجربة لا تتجاوز تكلفتها 100 ألف دولار
حتى تصنع قصة نجاح كبيرة
البعض يقول: يا أخي 250 تجربة
و 100 ألف دولار
و100 ألف دولار؛ مرة كثير
لكن ترى هذه طبيعة الابتكارات
أنت اليوم عندك أشياء مجهولة كثيرة؛ فلا بد أن تجرب
فهذا جزء من الثقافة
لا بد أن تبني ثقافة أننا نتقبل الأمور الغامضة المجهولة
مثل ما ذكرنا احنا اليوم كثير من الأشياء حولنا ماهي واضحة
المشكلات الموجودة أسبابها غير واضحة
فإذا بننتظر أن يصير كل شيء مرة واضح علشان ناخذ إجراء
هذا لن ينفع
فلا بد أننا نتبع منهجية معينة ونمضي
والأمور ستتضح فيما بعد
أيضًا لا بد أن نركز على الإنسان واحتياجاته
كيف تبني منظمة تتمحور حول الإنسان؟
يوم رحت شركة أمازون في «سان فرانسيسكو»
ما زلت أتذكر يا عبدالرحمن أول جملة تكلموا عنها
المهمة حقتنا
نريد أن نكون أكثر شركة تتمحور حول الإنسان في العالم
واضحة، جريئة
التمحور حول الإنسان يعني أن نبدأ من الإنسان واحتياجاته
وننتهي بتجريب الخدمة أو المنتج مع الإنسان
حتى نتأكد أنها تلبي احتياجاته
شلون نبني هذه كثقافة؟
ترى الكلام سهل
جدًّا
لكن التطبيق في غاية صعوبة
أيضًا من الأشياء اللي احنا نقول حتى تصبح مبتكرًا
لا بد أن تؤمن بأن نحلة واحدة لا تصنع العسل
هو عمل جماعي
الابتكار يحب التقاء الأفكار والتقاء العقول
تنمية روح العمل الجماعي في الشركات هذا يحتاج إلى عمل
بعض الشركات مبنية على أن كل واحد يخلص شغله ويمشي
فنحتاج إلى أن نبني هذا كثقافة
نحن نعمل كفريق ننمو كفريق
أيضًا من الأمور التي نتكلم عنها عادة
شلون تبني في الشركة حب بناء النماذج الأولية؟
يقولون: إذا كانت الصورة أفضل من ألف كلمة
فالنموذج الأولي أفضل من ألف صورة
أيش هو النموذج الأولي؟
هو تجسيد هذه الفكرة التي في مخك أو على الورق
إلى شيء مرئي أو ملموس يسهل شرحه للآخرين
أنا إذا جيت قلت لك عبدالرحمن بنسوي تطبيق جوال يسوي كذا وكذا
تخيل أني أعطيك هذا الكلام مكتوب
أو أني أجيك بنموذج فيه اللي هي الواجهات
والنموذج هذا قد يكون على الورق مكتوب
لكن أنقلك من واجهة إلى واجهة
هذا أفضل بكثير من مجرد كلام مكتوب
فهذه تصبح ثقافة في الشركة
كل شيء يمكن نمذجته
فأيضًا نحتفي بالأشخاص الذين يجربون ويحاولون ويفشلون
تقبّل الفشل لا بد أن يكون جزء من ثقافة، بل وسياسات الشركة
شلون تبني سياسات وإجراءات في الشركة
تسمح للناس أن يجربوا وتحميهم في حال الفشل؟
هذا جزء مهم
أنت اليوم في شركة «بوكينق»
شركة «بوكينق» يقولون
احنا من أهم قيمنا أننا نجرب ولا نخاف
ففي إحدى المرات قرروا أنهم يجربون تغيير على المنصة
وكان في فترة أعياد والناس بتحجز وكذا وبتسافر
فكان الشخص المسؤول المدير الكبير
في قمة الخوف من هذه التجربة
على الرغم من أنهم يقدرون يفصلون يجربون على عينات من الزبائن
لكن كان يخاف أن الأثر يمتد إلى زبائن آخرين
يبدون يتكلمون ويسولفون
طبعًا التغيير أحيانًا يغيرون مكان زر الاشتراك
أحيانًا يغيرون بعض الأشياء في الواجهة
يقولون: طيب ليه ما أوقفت هذه التجربة؟ أنت المدير
قال: هذا يتعارض مع قيم الشركة
احنا قلنا أننا نجرب ولا نخاف
ونعطي كل موظف الحق بالتجريب
ما دام يتبع إجراءات معينة
يعلن عن التجربة، يوضّح المقصود منها، ويشاركنا النتائج
فما نقدر هذه ثقافتنا وهذه سياستنا
أيش كانوا يبقون يغيرون؟
كانوا يبون يغيرون زر الاشتراك وطريقة طلب البحث عن الفنادق
فهو يقول: لو جاوا وقالوا نبغى نجرب
نغيّر اللون الأزرق المعروف إلى لون بنفسجي؛ لقبلت
مادام هذا في باب التجربة، ما عندي أي مشكلة
فنحتاج إلى بناء مثل هذه الثقافة عندنا في الشركات
أن الناس تجرب
احنا مرة متشددين ترى ونخاف من التجربة
نخاف من الفشل
«جيف بيزوس» يقول
التجربة التي تكون متأكد من نجاحها ليست التجربة
صحيح
التجربة مضنة الفشل
في «بوكينق» نسبة الفشل عندهم 90%
واو!
90%، لكن 10% تكفي وتنفع
وهي اللي تخليهم متقدمين
هي اللي تخليهم متقدمين
فشلون نبني هذه الثقافة في الشركات
أننا نعطي الناس المساحة أنها تجرب وتفشل
بل ونحتفي ونحتفل بهؤلاء (الفاشلين)
أنت لما تبني سياسة وإجراءات وثقافة
ما يحتاج موظفك يجي يقولك
ترى يا عبدالرحمن بسوي تجربة
ما يحتاج
أنا أقول عادةً اللي يبي يجرب لا يستشير
لأنك أنت فعليًّا إذا جيت استشرت مديرك
أنت تشركه في المخاطرة
والمدير عنده ما يكفيه
يقول لك: لا، لا تجرب ولا شيء
لكن يا أخي جرب
طبعًا يحتاج إلى أن تكون البيئة والسياسات والإجراءات تدعمه وتحميه
فهذه نحتاجها حتى نبني شركة مبتكرة
ولهذا نقول أن قادة الشركات
يحتاجوا إلى أن يستثمروا الكثير من وقتهم وجهدهم وأموالهم
في دعم عجلة الابتكار داخل الشركة
يوم جات الجائحة أذكر بدأت كثير من الشركات تبحث
تقول لموظفينها عطونا أفكار
إذا لم تكن قد زرعت من قبل
بيكون صعب جدًّا
ما يمديك تحصد في يوم، ما يمديك أبدًا
وأحيانًا أشبّه هذه الرحلة، خصوصًا بناء الثقافة
باللي يبي يزرع شجر «الصنوبر»
شجر «الصنوبر» يحتاج إلى خمسة وعشرين سنة حتى ينبت
لا إله إلا الله
طبعًا احنا ما نقول الابتكار يحتاج إلى خمسة وعشرين سنة
لكن نقول أنه يحتاج إلى وقت طويل
«القرع» بالمقابل تسعين يوم
فبعض الناس هو فعليًّا كل مرة يبي «قرع»
طيب متى ستزرع «الصنوبر»؟
لا إراديًّا أو ضمنيًّا
يقول: هذه رحلة طويلة ما أبغاها
لكن هذه طبيعة الابتكار
ترى الابتكار من وجهة نظري مثل سباق «الماراثون»
سباق «الماراثون» سباق طويل
إحدى الدراسات تقول
«أنك تحتاج إلى ألف فكرة حتى تحصل على فكرة واحدة ناجحة»
ألف فكرة من الأفكار التي تأتي على البال والخاطر
يعني أنك تحتاج إلى عمل كثير
وهذه الأفكار كلها ستتفلتر في مراحل معينة
وتقوم بإجراءات وتجريب واختبار
حتى تحصل على فكرة واحدة
ليه نقول هذا الكلام؟
لأن بعض الناس يعتقد أنه...
يا أخي طلعنا بمئة فكرة ولا طلع منها شيء
إيه هذا طبيعي
ومن المهم في الشركات
أن قادة الشركات والمدراء فيها يدركوا أن هذا طبيعي
تحتاج إلى عدد كبير من الأفكار
ومراحل كثيرة من التجريب
حتى تحصل على نجاح واحد كبير
صحيح، أتذكر قوقل أنهم يعطون الظهر 20%
من وقت موظفيهم للعمل على أشياء جانبية
ومنها طلع جيميل وخرائط قوقل وغيرها
فمساحات الإبداع والابتكار أحس أنها مهمة
وبأي طريقة منهجية مختلفة
وفيه على التعداد
وحتى المستثمرين
تجد المستثمرين والشركات الاستثمارية
يدري أنه بيستثمر في ألف فكرة لألف شركة
أو مئة شركة ويدري أنه يمكن إلى 97% منها تكون خسرانة
لكن ثنتين هي بتعوضه عن كل ما سبق
أحسنت، لكن تخيل لو هذا المستثمر قال
أنا ما أبغى أستثمر إلا في فكرة أكون متأكد أنها بتنجح
تخيل لو هذا المستثمر جرب أربع أو خمس أفكار وفشل
وقال ما أبغى هذا الموضوع كله
وهذا ما يحدث أحيانًا في بعض الجهات أو الشركات
يجرب كذا شوي وما ضبط شيء؛ يتوقف
الابتكار يحتاج إلى وقت
اليوم لك ست سنين في هذا المجال
عطني تجربة للفشل وتقبّلته
لأنك قبل شوي عطيتني كلام، ودي أشوف مثال
شوف مثلًا أنا في مشروعي الخاص
قد لا يكون فشل فشل، لكنه شبه فشل
ما عليك بنحتفي بالفشل
بالضبط
شوف أنا أطلقت منصة «ريّا»
هي منصة لصناعة الأطفال المبتكرين
صنعنا فيها محتوى
أزعم أنه محتوى فريد لا مثيل له في الوطن العربي كله
يدرب الأطفال على التفكير التصميمي من خلال القصة
القصة هي أفضل وسيلة لإيصال المعلومة
فاستخدمنا القصة حتى ندرب الأطفال على الابتكار
وأعطيناهم تمارين عملية
المحتوى تم مراجعته من واحد من أكبر المعاهد
المتخصصة في العالم في التفكير التصميمي
فصنعنا محتوى مميز
المشكلة أننا كنا نعتقد أن الأهالي سيتهافتون على هذا المنتج
فالشيء اللي ما كنا نعرفه
أن هناك بون شاسع بين ما نظن وبين واقع الحال
وجدنا أن الأهالي أنفسهم لا يعرفون معنى الابتكار
فما بالك أن يعززوا الابتكار لدى أبنائهم!
فهذا درس تعلمناه
الدرس الأهم، أن لا تسأل من هم مثلك وأمثالك من المهتمين
احنا يوم كنا نسوي الدراسات الأولى
ونشوف مدى اهتمام الناس
كل الناس كانوا يبون المنتج
لكن بعدين يوم رجعنا وبدأنا نسأل
اللي كنا نسألهم كلهم مثلنا
كلهم أناس مهتمين في هذا المجال
لكن هناك أناس كثيرين بعيدين جدًّا عن هذا الموضوع
فهذه واحدة من التجارب
طبعًا في العمل هناك تجارب كثيرة
يمكن ما نقدر نتكلم عنها
لكن هناك تجارب كثيرة لأفكار طلعت وقتلناها
وأحيانًا قتل الفكرة ليس بالأمر السهل
نتردد كثيرًا في قتل الأفكار الغير ناجحة لأسباب كثيرة
أحيانًا الناس تتعلق عاطفيًّا بهذه الأفكار
وهذه من الرسائل اللي دائمًا أتحدث عنها
لا تتعلّق بالفكرة تعلّق بالمشكلة
لا بد أنك تحدد المشكلة اللي أنت تحاول تحلها
ثم تصبح مرن في أي فكرة يمكن أن تساعدني في حل هذه المشكلة
لكن فكرتك الأولى قد لا تكون صحيحة أبدًا
فأن تستمر فيها وتتمسك فيها وتقول
سأظل أحاول وأحارب لسنوات
لا أعتقد أن هذا المنطق صحيح
فيه كثير من الشركات تأخذ فكرة الابتكار
وتبدأ تحاول تطبقها على شكل
يشوفون مثلًا مكاتب قوقل يبدون يغيرون الطاولات
وتصير الأماكن فرايحية وألوان وكذا
صحيح
ما مدى تأثير هذا على طبيعة الابتكار في الشركات؟
قريت كتاب «بيلد» لـ«توني فاضل»؟
إذا ما قربته؛ بهديك الكتاب إن شاء الله
أبد، الشرف لي
هذا من الكتب اللي ضاق صدري يوم انتهيت منها
وكنت أسمع له مسموع في السيارة
لأني صرت أبحث عن ونيس في هذه الطريق
«توني فاضل» هو مبتكر الآيبود لشركة أبل
وقائد فريق صناعة أول جهاز آيفون لأبل
هو لا يؤمن بهذا كله
الشيء اللي موجود والمكان
بل هو ناقم جدًّا على قوقل
للامتيازات الكثيرة التي يعطونها لموظفيهم
أبل ما عندهم كل هذا، لكنهم ما زالوا مبتكرين
مع تحفظنا على الإصدارات الأخيرة
وفي الجانب الآخر، قوقل أيضًا مبتكرين
لا شك أن هذا يساعد
تهيئة المكان وجعله مكان جذاب
وداعي للناس حتى تأتي وتجلس وتجرب
هذا مطلوب
لكن الفكرة أنك شلون تشغّل هذا المكان، تحييه؟
أكاد أجزم أن عدد كبير من معامل الابتكار التي يتم بنائها
ينتهي بها المقام صالة اجتماعات جميلة
ليه يا عبدالرحمن؟ لأن الجزء هذا سهل، عمل مقاولات
لكن الجزء الصعب هو التشغيل
شلون تجعل هذا المكان منبع للأفكار
منبع للتجارب، منبع لالتقاء العقول؟
شلون تخليه بيئة جاذبة للناس؟
أي واحد عنده فكرة يأتي ويجلس ويجرب فيها
وتستمر وتصبر على هذا لفترة طويلة؟
هذا تحدي جدًّا كبير
الحين إذا أنا عندي شركة سويت شغل المقاولات
ورتبت غرف الاجتماعات بشكل رائع
هل الحين أني أنا أصنع البيئة وللا أوظف المبدعين؟ أيهما أولى؟
الأهم من وجهة نظري هم المبدعين
ومن ثم تصنع هم بيصنعون بيئة بالضرورة؟
وإلا البيئة قد تقتل المبدعين؟
البيئة لا تقتصر على العفش
البيئة هي مجموع المكان المحيط بهؤلاء المبدعين
فالبيئة فيها المدراء، السياسات، الإجراءات، الحوافز
هذه كلها تساهم في بناء البيئة
والمكان هو جزء لا شك من البيئة
لكن هناك كثير من المبدعين يبدعون في مكاتبهم
أو المبتكرين في مكاتبهم
المكان ممتاز، جيد أن يكون عندك مكان
بل بعض الباحثين يقولون: مهم أن يكون عندك مكان
لكن الاهتمام بهؤلاء هو الجزء الأهم
تقول أنت أحد موانع الابتكار هي الخلط بين الافتراض والحقيقة
أيش الفرق؟
الافتراض هي معلومة ليس عليها دليل
فأنا الآن مثلًا إذا شفت سلوك معين
قد أفترض شيء معين بدون دليل
بناءً على خبرة، تجربة
الابتكار ميزته أنه يعتمد على حقائق وأدلة وبيانات
ولهذا ندعو دائمًا حتى تصبح مبتكرًا
أن تكون متجردًا وتبحث عن الأدلة والحقائق
بعض الناس يكون عنده افتراض معين
بناءً على  تجربة أو خبرة أو معرفة
ويظن أن هذا الافتراض صالح لكل زمان ومكان
ولهذا كتبت مرة أن المبتدئ أحيانًا أفضل من الخبير، ليه؟
المبتدئ يسأل، ما يخاف عادي مبتدئ
المبتدئ ليس لديه افتراضات أصلًا
هو جاي ما يعرف شيء
و كذلك المبتدئ عادةً لو فشل أو أخطأ؛ عادي مبتدئ
وهذه العقلية اللي دائمًا ندعو الناس إلى تبنيها
إذا أرادوا أن يكونوا مبتكرين
نقول أحيانًا تحتاج إلى أن تتبنى عقلية المبتدئ
بل حتى عقلية الطفل
الطفل يميزه أنه ما يخاف من السؤال، يسأل ستين سؤال
وأنت أحيانًا تحتاج إلى هذا؟
فالأشخاص أحيانًا مع تراكم الخبرة أو المعرفة
للأسف الشديد يصبحون أقل فضولًا
وأكثر ركونًا للمعرفة اللي عندهم والخبرة
فلو جيتك قلت: يا عبدالرحمن أيش رأيك نسوي كذا؟
قلت: ما يصلح، ما ينفع قد جربناها قبل، وإلا سوينا هذا
هذا كله يقتل الابتكار
فلا بد أنك تكون منفتح وعادي
أنا عندي معلومة أُدرك ضمنيًّا أن هذا افتراض
أحيانًا تبني قراراتك على حدس عادي
لكن لا بد أن تعرف وتدرك
أنك بنيت هذا القرار على حدس وليس على بيانات
لهذا في شركة «تويوتا» يقولون: احنا لا نلتفت إلا إلى البيانات
لو جيت أنت مدير كبير في الشركة وأنا موظف صغير
جئنا بحل لمشكلة معينة
لا تؤخذ فكرة الموظف الكبير لأنه كبير
وتُترك فكرة الموظف الصغير لأنه صغير
تؤخذ فكرة الشخص الذي لديه بيانات
أنا جربت حلي؛ أستطيع أن أثبت بالبيانات أنه نافع يحل المشكلة
وأنت يا عبدالرحمن مدير كبير
لديك رأيك الذي لا يستند على بيانات
الأصل أن نأخذ رأي هذا الشخص
الذي لديه فكرة مجربة مبنية على بيانات
فالافتراض يُترك حتى يتم التحقق منه، وهذا مهم جدًّا
احنا في الابتكار نعمل كثيرًا على التحقق من الافتراضات
أن تمضي بافتراض وتبني منتج
كما افترضت أنا في موضوع الأهالي؛ هذا خطأ كبير
وأحيانًا يجب أن ندرك أن الدماغ لا يعطينا الصورة الكاملة
ولا يعطينا حقيقة الشيء الذي نرى أمامنا
يقولون: أن الدماغ يحتاج من ثانيتين إلى ثلاث ثواني
للحكم على الشخص الذي يراه لأول مرة، لكنه يخطئ بنسبة 50%
وهكذا كثير من الأشياء التي نراها في العمل وكذا
ولهذا كتبت مرة عن نظرية «البقدونس»
حتى قال لي واحد من الشباب: يا أخي غيّر اسمها
سميها كذا نظرية «البستاشيو» حتى يكون لها مكان
نظرية «البقدونس» بكل بساطة أنت إذا رحت إلى محل الخضار
تشتري بقدونس وأحيانًا أمثالي يلخبطون بين البقدونس والكزبرة
كلنا ذاك الرجل
أنا أقول هذه من المشاكل التي ثمنها ريال
لكن الدمج فيها ممكن يكلف 100 ألف ريال
إذا رجعت البيت
صحيح
هل ستأخذ أي واحدة بناءً على افتراض
تقول: أعتقد أن هذا هو البقدونس أو هذا الكزبرة وتمضي؟
لا
ستتوقف، ستحاول أن تنظر إلى الملصق
تبحث، إذا ما كان فيه ملصق؛ ستسأل
أحيانًا قد تضطر إلى أن تجرب
شلون تجرب؟ يعني تشمّه، فيه فرق
الكزبرة لها رائحة مختلفة
فتحتاج إلى أن تسأل أحيانًا، تجرب وتبحث
نفس الشيء في بعض القرارات التي تتخذها
هي نسبة بسيطة من القرارات التي نتخذها في يومنا
دماغنا سبحان الله يتخذ آلاف القرارات في اليوم ونحن لا ندري
لكن ثمّة قرارات تتعلق بالأعمال وحياة الناس والحكم عليهم
لا بد أن تتنبّه لها
تدرك أنك في هذه اللحظة ستتخذ قرار
فتتريث قليلًا، تطبق
نظرية «البقدونس»
من الأشياء الطريفة كنت أتحدث مع مجموعة من الزملاء
فكنت أقول أنا ألخبط بين البقدونس والكزبرة
يقول: تدري أنا واللهِ ألخبط بين البقدونس والجرجير
لا إله إلا الله، عنده مشكلة
يا ابن الحلال -لا إله إله الله- شلون تلخبط؟
قال: والله ألخبط بينهم
قلت: الله المستعان
لا إله إلا الله، والله هذه مشكلة
كيف يلخبط؟!
ما أدري والله، يحلف يمين الله على المستعان
سبحان الله، على الحقائق والأرقام
المثال اللي ذكرته مثلًا في «تويوتا»
أحس أنه يختلف مع فكرة الإبداع والابتكار إلى حدٍ كبير
فتلقى «جيف بيزوس» مثلًا مثال بما أنك استشهدت بأمازون كثيرًا
كان يقول: أن أهم القرارات في حياتي المهنية والحياتية
اتخذتها بناءً على الحدس، لم تكن مبنية على الحقائق والأرقام
صحيح
كيف تسوي؟ المنطقي أن الحدس دائم يقودك إلى شيء آخر
صحيح، الحدس مهم، لكن لا بد أن تدرك
أنك بنيت قراراتك بناءً على حدس وليس بناءً على بيانات
لأنك ستحتاج إلى أن تتأكد من أن هذا الحدس صحيح
لا أحد يتخذ قرار كذا بناءً على حدس
ويمضي لمسافات طويلة دون أن يمر بسلسلة من مراحل التحقق
من أن حدسي هذا صحيح
فهذا مطلوب
احنا نقول دائمًا: لا بأس أن تتخذ قرارك بناءً على حدس
لكن ينبغي أن تكون واعي
لأن هذا القرار أُتخذ بناءً على حدس وليس بناءً على حقائق وبيانات
لأني لو بتخيل واحد في «تويوتا» ويجي يقول
والله أنا أعتقد أن الآن -هذا الكلام  في 2013- وقت مناسب
ويجب أن نبدأ الآن صناعة السيارات الكهربائية
ويجي الآخر بالأرقام ويقول لك
ما في ولا دليل يثبت أن الناس تبغى تشتري سيارات كهربائية
صحيح
وين بيروح؟ وكذا بتفشل «تويوتا» لو هذا واقع الأمر
اليوم فيه السيارات الكهربائية
صحيح، وهذه واحدة من التحديات في الأبحاث عمومًا
عادةً في الابتكار نبدأ من احتياج
لا بد أن يكون ثمة مشكلة
في الأبحاث طويلة المدى
ليس شرطًا أن تكون ثمة مشكلة
هم يتوقعون أنه ستكون هناك مشكلة في المستقبل
وهي مثل ما كنت أكلم أحد المدراء التنفيذيين في «مايكروسوفت» مثل المقامرة
أنت تعتقد أنه سيكون هناك شيء كبير في المستقبل
فتضع أموالك هناك، وتستثمر بجهد وقوة وكذا
هذا في الأبحاث أحيانًا بعض الجهات
أو حتى الحكومات تستثمر استثمار
مدته خمسة وعشرين سنة في صناعة شيء جديد
وبالتأكيد هي مغامرة قد توصلك إلى مكان جدًّا كبير
وقد لا توصلك إلى أي مكان
لكن في الابتكار احنا عادةً نبدأ من احتياجات الإنسان
من المشكلات الحقيقية
نحاول أن نبحث عن جذور هذه المشكلات ثم نعالجها
لو جيت أنا وعرضت عليك فكرة
متى بتقول تمام باخذ حدسك على الأرقام؟
إذا عرضت علي فكرة أطلب منك أن تجربها
أول شيء لا بد أن تعرف من هو العميل الذي تخدمه
ثم تبني هذه الافتراضات اللي موجودة عندك
تقول أنا بنيتها بناءً على حدس
حدسي يقول: العميل سيدفع، تحل المشكلة، كذا كذا
نقول: ممتاز هذه نكتبها، ثم نذهب ونتحقق منها
شلون؟ نقابل أصحاب المشكلة
نقول: هذا عندك النموذج الأولي، هل يحل المشكلة؟
هل مستعد أن تدفع مقابل هذه الخدمة؟ هل كذا، هل كذا؟
نجمع هذه الآراء، ثم بعدها نحللها ونتخذ القرارات
في الشركات هي آخر نقطة
في عندنا اللي هو جلسات العصف الذهني
أيش الشكل المثالي لهذه الجلسات؟
أو أيش النقيض؟ أيش الأخطاء اللي تخلي الجلسات بأقل كفاءة؟
جميل، جلسات العصف الذهني الهدف منها الخروج بأفكار معينة
أحيانًا لحل مشكلة محددة
تمر بمرحلتين
المرحلة الأولى، يتم فيها جمع أكبر كم ممكن من الأفكار
وفي هذه المرحلة احنا نقول: يمنع أن نحكم على الأفكار
ما أقول فكرتك جيدة أو فكرتك سيئة
لا، نطلق العنان للتفكير أن يأتي بأي فكرة
هو يراها جيدة لهذه المشكلة أو لحل هذه المشكلة
فنتجنب الحكم على الأفكار، لا نناقشها في تلك المرحلة
نشجع الأفكار الغريبة
ما نناقشها، فقط ندوّنها مثلًا؟
فقط ندوّنها
ثم تأتي المرحلة الأخرى
طبعًا يقولون: في جلسة العصف الذهن الجيدة
خلال ساعة المفروض تطلع بمئة فكرة
ثم هذه الأفكار نذهب بها إلى المرحلة الأخرى
وهنا نحكّم المنطق ونبدأ بالحكم على الأفكار
بناءً على معايير معينة يحتاجها صاحب الورشة أو الجلسة
فعادةً احنا نحكم بناءً على معيارين
سهولة التنفيذ والأثر
فنبحث احنا عن أفكار سهلة التنفيذ وذات أثر كبير
وهكذا نسوي عادةً الفلترة هذه
ويتم بعدين عملية التصويت
فكل واحد نعطيه إمكانية للتصويت يسموها نقاط التصويت
مثل ملصق صغير أو بالقلم
ونقول الأفضل لا تصوّت لفكرتك
حتى لا يصبح الناس متحيزين
صوّت لأي أفكار أخرى
عندك مثلًا صوتين تحط هنا هنا
نرى بالأخير الفكرة التي حازت على أكبر عدد ممكن الأصوات
نأخذها إلى المرحلة التالية
هذه باختصار ورشة العصف الذهني
قبل برضه بروح التفكير التصميمي لأن ذكرته أنت كثيرًا
بس آخر حاجة بجي لدور الحكومات بعد الشركات
في تحفيز المجتمع أن يصبح مجتمع ابتكاري
أعتقد أحد الأشياء اللي دائمًا
تُظلم فيها الشركات العربية
مثل القائمة اللي أنت حطيتها، الألف اللي ذكرتها
في أمريكا ومعظم الدول
أن الشركات تضع مراكز للأبحاث لتوفير الفلوس
لأن الحكومات تحفزهم
فتقول: أنت بتدفع ضريبة بتدفع الضريبة
تبغاني أعفيك من الضريبة؟
الفلوس التي تصرفها في الأبحاث هي معفية من الضريبة
فلذا يصير، ليش ما أبحث وهي فلوس أنا بالفعل خسرانها
وهذا غير موجود هنا، فالحافز هذا المهم غير موجود
وهنا يكمن مثلًا دور الحكومات
فكيف ممكن -لو تعطيني أمثلة- الدور الحقيقي للحكومات
في تحفيز الابتكار في المجتمع؟
صحيح، هو الدور كما ذكرت أنت عبدالرحمن
دور الحكومات هو تحفيز وتشجيع وتمكين القطاعات حتى تبتكر
هذا دور الحكومات
وهذا موجود اليوم كما ذكرت في دول كثيرة
أمريكا هي المثال الأوضح
لكنه موجود في فرنسا وبريطانيا، في الصين، في سنقافورة
كلها تعمل بنفس الطريقة
تحدد مجالات للبحث، تستثمر في البحوث العلمية فيها
تعطيك منحة
تدعم إنشاء مراكز الأبحاث
تخفّض عنك الضريبة
تساعدك في عملية جذب العاملين في هذه الجهات
من خلال تسهيلات وقوانين
وبهذه الطريقة هي توجّه التوجه العام للبحث والابتكار في هذه البلد
وأنا أشوف صراحة من الخطوات الممتازة اللي صارت مؤخرًا
هي إنشاء هيئة تنمية البحث والابتكار والتطوير
وأعتقد هذه مهمتها أنها تدفع بعجلة الابتكار
من خلال سن القوانين والتشريعات
وتمويل الجهات التي تعمل وتمكينها
والسعودية حددت أماكن برضه
ووجهت أماكن للبحث والتطوير السنة الماضية أعتقد
حددوها في أربع نقاط
اليوم أنا أشوف هيئة البحث والابتكار والتطوير
بدأت تحاول أن تسد الفجوة
اللي موجودة بين الجامعات مثلًا والشركات
في هذه القطاعات، أنا نسيت القطاعات الأربعة
لكن نقول: إذا جئت بموضوع بحثي، وجبت معك شريك
أنت كشركة، جبت معك شريك أكاديمي
وقررتم أن تعملوا على هذا البحث بمخرجات محددة
أنا أموّل هذا البحث
وهذا الشيء مطلوب، وهذا شيء مميز
ونشوف الحراك اللي موجود اليوم في إنشاء «الكراج»
حراك مميز جدًّا
و«إم بي بي لاب» وغيرها من المبادرات
هذه بإذن الله تدعونا إلى التفاؤل اللي كان موجود في البداية
وأنا أعتقد أن احنا مجتمع لا يتقبل الفشل
بالعكس أحسه ينزل فيك ويجلدك على أي فشل أن تسويه
هذا تحدي ما أدري من المسؤول عن تغييره، لكنه...
يا عبدالرحمن إذا داخل الشركات أحيانًا
اللي هي المفروض عندها أمثلة واضحة وصريحة
كثير منها لا تتقبل الفشل، فالمجتمع من باب أولى
لكن رحلة التغيير والتطوير تبدأ بخطوة
وأنا أعتقد أن احنا اتخذنا في المملكة هذه الخطوة
فلو أنا باخذ الخطوة التالية التفكير التصميمي
ما هو التفكير التصميمي؟
التفكير التصميمي أو «design thinking»
أحيانًا نذكر المصطلحات الإنقليزية حتى يعرف الناس
لأن أحيانًا التعريب غير متفق عليه كثيرًا
فالتفكير التصميمي هو منهجية لإيجاد الحلول الإبداعية للمشكلات
ما معنى منهجية؟
مجموعة من الخطوات التي نتبعها
حتى نوجد حلًّا إبداعيًّا لمشكلة موجودة
هذا بكل بساطة
المنهجية فيها خمس خطوات سهلة بسيطة
الخطوة الأولى، هي التقمص أو التعاطف
وهي بكل بساطة أن تضع نفسك مكان الآخرين
حتى تفهم أكثر عن المشكلة التي يعانون منها
وهنا تأتي قوة التفكير التصميمي
أنه واقعي ومنطقي، لا يعتمد على افتراضات
فأنا إذا أردت أن أحل مشكلة لمريض
ليس من العقل أن أحل مشكلة المريض وأنا جالس في مكتبي
لا بد أن أذهب وأقابل المريض أو أراقب المريض
فهذا هو التعاطف
وهناك ثلاث طرق بسيطة
الأولى، أن أذهب وأقابل هؤلاء الأشخاص
أسألهم بعض الأسئلة عن مشكلتهم ليه هي موجودة؟
أيش تفاصيل هذه المشكلة اللي يمرون فيها؟
وأحاول هنا في هذا البحث أن أصل إلى جذور المشكلة
هناك منهجية بالمناسبة عند «تويوتا» أيضًا
اسمها «لماذا خمس مرات»
بكل بساطة هي تقول: إذا سألت لماذا خمسة مرات
ستصل بإذن الله إلى جذر المشكلة
احنا لا نكتفي بالإجابة السطحية الأولى
لا بد أننا نخوض في أعماق المشكلة حتى نفهم جذورها
وهذا ذكرني بمثال
هناك نُصب مشهور في واشنطن اسمه نُصب «جيفرسون»
هو عبارة عن مبنى مسقوف من الأعلى
ومن الجوانب هناك أعمدة فهو مفتوح
وفي الداخل هناك تمثال لرئيس أمريكا السابق اسمه «توماس جيفرسون»
يقولون: كان عندهم مشكلة كبيرة
أن الطيور تأتي وتضع روثها -أكرمك الله- في ذاك المكان
وعمليات التنظيف مستمرة ومكلفة
والسياح يأتون إلى هذا المكان بكثرة
فالموضوع متعب ومربك
وجلسوا على هذا الحال لفترة طويلة بس ينظفون كل يوم
الين جاء واحد
واحنا دائمًا نبغى ذاك الواحد
اللي قال: يا أخي ليه هذه الطيور
تترك كل الحديقة والبحيرة ما تجي إلا على هذا المكان؟
قالوا: أيوة والله صحيح، ليه؟
قال: الطيور يبدو أنها تأتي لأن هناك عناكب
قالوا: طيب ممتاز، لكن العناكب أيش جابها؟
قال: العناكب تأتي على الحشرات؟
قالوا: طيب ليه الحشرات تأتي إلى هذا المكان؟
فكروا وفكروا، قالوا: لأن هذا المكان هو المكان الوحيد
الذي يضاء في الليل في تلك المنطقة
فالحشرات تطير وتجلس في هذا المكان ليلًا
فتأتيها العناكب
فتأتيها الطيور
بالضبط، فقالوا: طيب خلنا نجرب
لو خفّضنا الإنارة ننظر ماذا يحدث
فخفّضوا الإنارة؛ خفّت الحشرات، خفّت العناكب، خفّت الطيور
طبعًا خفّت الفضلات فخفّت عمليات التنظيف
واو!
كانت نقطة التحول
أن ثمة شخص قرر أن يقول لماذا؟
وهذا الشيء اللي نبغاه
نبغى هؤلاء يكون عندهم المساحة أنهم يقولون ليه؟
هذا مهم ومو بسهل
في الشركات إذا كنا نتكلم عن الشركات
أعطي الناس مساحة تشعر أنها في أمان
أنها تسأل عن أي شيء وعن كل شيء
فهذا يسموه السلامة النفسية
أنا أسميه هذا اللبنة الأساسية في بناء الابتكار في أي مكان
أن يشعر الموظف أو الطفل أنه في أمان
يستطيع أن يسأل ويتساءل دون لوم
فهذه عملية المقابلة في التعاطف
التعاطف ثلاث طرق
أول شيء نقابل أصحاب المشكلة
الشيء ثاني، أن نراقب
طيب معليش قبل المراقبة عشان ما نطلع
ودي تعطي مثال لماذا أعطي الخمسة أو الخمسة لماذا
يعني غير...
غير هذا؟
هل أني أسأل بس خمس مرات؟ ليه؟ ليه؟ وللا أيش؟
لا، أنت تسأل بناءً
وللا هي أسئلة معينة؟
بناءً على الإجابة
مثلًا احنا كان في إحدى المرات عندنا مشكلة
لماذا لا نصنع منتجات جديدة؟
عندنا مشكلة في التمويل
إيه هي مشكلة التمويل؟
ليه عندك مشكلة في التمويل؟ عندك ميزانية
يقول: أنا الميزانية أستخدمها في مكان آخر
لماذا استخدمها في المكان الآخر؟
لأني أراه أسهل
أنت ليست مشكلتك في وجود تمويل
مشكلتك أنك تريد شيء أسهل
ترى أنه هذا شيء صعب
فالجواب الأول ليس هو الجواب الصحيح
فلو أعطيته تمويل أكثر لن تحل المشكلة
سيذهب بها إلى المكان الأسهل وهكذا
ممتاز، الحين نجي للمراقبة
المراقبة، تذهب إلى المكان وتراقب أصحاب المشكلة
تراقب سلوكهم
المراقبة أحيانًا تخليك تشوف سلوكيات
قد لا يستطيع الناس أن يعبروا عنها لو سألتهم
لكن حالهم يخبرك أشياء كثيرة
وأحيانًا المراقبة تعطيك أسئلة وليس فقط إجابات
فأنت تشوف سلوك معين؛ ما تدري ليه سوى كذا
فتغطيه بالمقابلة
فتبدأ عادةً في الملاحظة والمراقبة وترصّد السلوكيات
ثم تتبعها بالمقابلات حتى تفسر بعض السلوكيات
الطريقة الأخيرة، أن تضع نفسك تمامًا مكان الآخرين
شلون؟ لو جيت تبغى تطور تجربة الناس
اللي جالسين على الكرسي المتحرك في الطوارئ
تستطيع أن تراقب، أن تقابل
لكن ستكون تجربة مختلفة
لو جلست بنفسك على الكرسي المتحرك ومشيت في الطوارئ
فهذه تعطيك الشعور
اللي قد لا تجده في المقابلات ولا في المراقبة
فمجموع هذا كله يعطينا فهم أعمق
للمشكلة التي يعاني منها هذا الشخص
ولهذا نسمي هذه المرحلة هي قلب وروح التفكير التصميمي
مرحلة التعاطف
هي الأساس هي التي نبني فيها الفهم العميق للمشكلة
ثم بعدها نأخذ هذا الفهم إلى مرحلة تعريف المشكلة
نحلل كل هذه البيانات اللي جبناها
ونطلع بتعريف واضح للمشكلة
عادة يبدأون يطرحونها كسؤال
لأن السؤال يدعو للإجابة
فيقولون: دائمًا السؤال يبدأ بماذا لو؟ كيف يمكننا أن؟
فمثلًا تقول: كيف يمكننا تحسين تجربة المرضى
على الكرسي المتحرك في أقسام الطوارئ؟
وأذكر مرة كنت أشتغل في قطاع الحج
وكان عندنا تحدي نريد أن نحسّن من تجربة
انتقال حجاج الخارج من مطار الملك عبدالعزيز في جدة
إلى السكن في مكة
وكان هذا قبل سنوات
فجينا وقلنا: خلنا نركب جهاز على باب الباص
حتى لا يتم تفتيش الباص في نقطة «الشمسي»
لأن كنا عندنا المشكلة مع كثرة الباصات
يصير هناك ازدحام على نقطة التفتيش
ليه يفتش؟ هو يفتش لأنه يبغى يتأكد
أن كل اللي موجودين في الباص هم حجاج مُصرح لهم
فبدأنا نفكر في كيف نركب جهاز «آي يو تي» على الباب؟
وشلون؟ وبدأنا نكلم شركات في هذا المجال
ثم توقفنا وقلنا: يا أخي السؤال الذي طرحناه مرة حادّنا في هذا الباب
فغيّرنا السؤال، قلنا: كيف يمكننا أن نقلل مدة انتقال حجاج الخارج
من مطار الملك عبدالعزيز في جدة
إلى السكن في مكة من ست ساعات إلى ساعتين؟
تلاحظ أن فيه رحابة، عندك مجال أوسع للابتكار
ذاك الأول مرة حدّنا في مجال معين أو في منطقة معينة
فلا بد أن يكون هذا السؤال الذي نحدده
مو مرة واسع ولا مرة ضيق مثل ذاك السؤال
فنحدد سؤال واحد، نطبعه كذا ونضعه أمامنا في مكان
يجب أن يكون سؤال واحد؟
يجب أن يكون سؤال واحد
لا تحاول أن تحل مشكلة كبيرة دفعة واحدة
وهذه من الأشياء المهمة اللي دائمًا نقولها للأشخاص
اللي يعملون على إيجاد الحلول
هذه المشكلة الكبيرة قسمها إلى مشاكل صغيرة
في رحلة الحاج أو رحلة العميل
احنا نرصد نقاط الألم
دائمًا نقول: لا تحاول أنك تقول أنا سأصنع رحلة مثالية
من بلد السفر إلى بلد السفر، وأنت فرد
هذا كبير
حاول أن تأخذ من هذه الرحلة الكبيرة
جزء معين مؤلم بما يكفي
يستحق أن تقضي فيه وقتك وجهدك ومالك أحيانًا
وتوجد حل هذه المشكلة، ثم تنتقل إلى مشكلة أخرى
علمتنا التجارب أن الأفكار الكبيرة والمعقدة
تموت قبل أن تولد، مهما كانت ابتكارية
فأنت خذ لك مشكلة محددة أوجد لها حلًا
بعض الناس يقول لك أنا أبغى أسوي حل
أحل مشكلة البطالة في السعودية
هذه المشكلة بتعمل عليها دولة بأكملها
لن تستطيع أنت كفرد ولا حتى كشركة أنت تحل هذه المشكلة
لكن ممكن تقول أنا سأساعد طلاب الجامعة
في مثلًا بناء سيرة ذاتية مميزة
في اختيار التخصص المناسب، في كذا
اللي هو يصب في النهاية في الهدف الكبير
ذكرني أن نرجع إلى مواصفات الفكرة المميزة
طيب، احنا قلنا الآن حددنا السؤال
بس دقيقة، أيش آلية تحديد السؤال المثالي؟
يوم جمعنا احنا كل المعطيات، فهمنا جذور المشكلة
الآن نحتاج إلى أن نطرح سؤال حول جذر المشكلة
هذا الجذر الذي عرفناه وحللناه؛ هنا يأتي السؤال
على سبيل المثال
وجدنا أن كل الأشخاص في غرف الطوارئ
يقولون: أن الكراسي مثلًا غير مريحة
كيف يمكننا أن نضمن رحلة مريحة
للمرضى الذين لا يستطيعون الوقوف في الطوارئ؟
هذا سؤال شوي واسع، لكنه غير ضيق مرة ولا واسع مرة
لو بضيقه كيف بيصير؟
من خلال كراسي مريحة
أنت كذا وضعت شبه إجابة
لأن قد لا تكون بالضرورة الحل في الكرسي نفسه
إيه، قد لا يكون الحل في الكرسي
قد يكون الحل في تسريع الإجراءات
أنا ما أبغاه يجلس أصلًا
فهذا السؤال، صار السؤال واضح
نضعه أمامنا في مكان حتى يصير فيه هناك موائمة
واتفاق بين كل أعضاء الفريق عندنا مهمة واحدة واضحة
بعدها نأتي إلى مرحلة توليد الأفكار
اللي هي العصف الذهني
نولّد عدد كبير من الأفكار ثم نحكم عليها
يقول أحد الفائزين بجاز «نوبل» للكيمياء
«إذا أردت أن تأتي بفكرة جيدة
فعليك أن تأتي بعدد كبير من الأفكار، ثم تختار الأفضل منها»
بعد التصويت وكذا، طلعنا بهذه الفكرة المميزة
نأخذها إلى مرحلة النمذجة، بناء النموذج الأولي
نحوّل هذه الفكرة إلى شيء ملموس
طبعًا النمذجة جاء لها أشكال كثيرة
أما أنك ترسم أو تصمم أو تستخدم مثلًا رسم ثلاثي الأبعاد
أي طريقة تستطيع أن تستخدمها
لتحويل هذه الفكرة إلى شيء واضح وظاهر
بأقل كلفة وأقل وقت
بأقل كلفة وبأقل وقت، ليه؟
لأن الأدوات أصبحت متاحة
أحسنت، طبعًا ليه نقول بأقل كلفة وبأقل وقت؟
لأن هذا سيتم التغيير عليه مرارًا وتكرارًا وفي الغالب سيُرمى
بعد ما بنينا النموذج الأولي
في الغالب سيُرمى؟
إيه، لأنك تحتاج أن تجرب كثيرًا
هذا الشكل لن يكون هو الشكل النهائي
ستأتي بنموذج جديد تمامًا
أذكر دُعيت إلى مؤتمر لشركة «آيديو» في «سان فرانسيسكو»
مؤتمر خاص
كان عندهم إحدى الحلول
يقولون: بنينا أكثر من 100 نموذج أولي
حتى وصلنا إلى هذه النسخة من الحل
أكثر من 100 نموذج أولي
فبعد ما نبني هذا النموذج الأولي نذهب لتجريبه
نجربه مع من؟ مع أصحاب المشكلة
وهذه نقطة مهمة، لا تجرب مع أهلك ولا أصدقائك
اللي تشعر أنهم بيتعاطفون معك
أذكر في إحدى المرات كان عندنا فكرة ونريد أن نتحقق منها
فبنينا النموذج الأولي لهذه الفكرة
ووضعنا مجموعة من الافتراضات
قلنا خلنا نروح ونقابل أصحاب المشكلة
فصاحب الفكرة كان موجود
قال: خلاص أنا بروح وبقابل مجموعة من المستخدمين
وفريق آخر ذهب وقابل مجموعة من المستخدمين
رجع الفريق الأول، قلنا لهم: كيف الأمور؟
قالوا: والله الناس ما تبغاها، ما تحل المشكلة
ذاك رجع، قلنا له: شلون؟
قال: الناس مرة تبغاها
قلنا: شلون؟!
بعد بحث وتمحيص، طلع سأل أهله وأصدقائه
أنت إذا رحت تسأل أمك أيش تقول لك؟
تتفاعل
ما في مثلك ولا مثل فكرتك
لا، وأحيانًا يقع الواحد في خطأ
أنك لما تسأل الناس عن فكرة
بيقول لك: حلوة
يمكن يشوفها حلوة
بس هل إذا صارت منتج بفلوس هل أنت بتشتريه؟
تلقى ما أحد بيشتريه
صحيح، لهذا أحيانًا احنا نروح إلى مرحلة أبعد
ونبني المنتج الأولي الـ «إم بي بي»
ونحاول في تلك المرحلة أن نختبر عادةً قابلية الناس للدفع
لأن أنت يوم تسأل الناس في النموذج الأولي
يعطيك إمكانية أنك تروح وتسولف مع الناس تسألهم
والناس هنا بوجهك بتجاملك في أغلب الأحيان
لكن إذا جيت وبنيت منتج أولي
وأطلقته مثلًا على الإنترنت كواجهات خفيفة
فيها أقل قدر ممكن من الميزات
ووضعت فيها إمكانية الدفع والاشتراك
هناك تعرف ردة الفعل الحقيقية للناس
بعد مرحلة بناء النموذج الأولي
نذهب إلى مرحلة الاختبار، وهذا اللي كنا نسولف عنها
نختبر، نجمع ردود وآراء المستخدمين ونعدّل
ونعدّل حتى نصل إلى النسخة المقبولة
اللي يقول لك المستخدم فعلًا هذه أبغاها
طبعًا هناك خلط بين التفكير التصميمي و«التشغيل المرن» كمنهجية
التفكير التصميمي عادةً ما يركز بشكل كبير
على قياس مدى رغبة الناس بالحل، الرغبة
احنا نستخدم بعد التفكير التصميمي في مرحلة متقدمة
الـ «التشغيل المرن» كمنهجية للتحقق من مدى قابلية الناس للدفع
أو عن مدى وجود سوق حقيقي لهذه الفكرة
فهناك نبني المنتج الأولي اللي هو الـ «إم بي بي»
ونحاول أن نتأكد من أن الناس
إذا رأت هذه الخدمة بهذه المواصفات؛ ستدفع مقابل هذه الخدمة
هذه الخمسة خطوات في التفكير التصميمي
تبدو سهلة وبسيطة
وتتبناها اليوم كبريات الشركات في العالم
من قوقل، مايكروسوفت، «آي بي إم» فيس بوك
كل هذه الشركات تبنّت التفكير التصميمي كمنهجية أساسية للابتكار
وأنا أدعو الشركات الموجودة هنا، حتى والأفراد
إلى تبني هذه المنهجية
وتبدأ المنهجية بوجود مشكلة
ولهذا من الأشياء اللي أيضًا نركز عليها في عملنا
أن نجعل الناس يبحثون عن المشكلات
أطلقنا قبل سنوات في الشركة حملة اسمها «نبي مشاكل»
تدورون مشاكل أنتم
شاركنا مشكلة، تشوفها حولك
طبعًا ستأتيك مشاكل كثيرة
أحيانًا بعضها منطقية، وبعضها غير منطقية
لكن أعطي الناس مساحة
حتى تشارك المشكلات والتحديات الموجودة حولها
بل حتى عندنا هناك أداة اسمها بنك الأفكار
احنا عندنا اسمها بنك الأفكار والتحديات
بنفس الطريقة التي ندعو الناس فيها لمشاركة الأفكار
ندعوهم أيضًا لمشاركة التحديات
بل نحاول أن ننشر في الشركة ثقافة
الجرأة لمشاركة ومناقشة التحديات سواءً الداخلية أو الخارجية
سواءً التي يعاني منها العميل الداخلي، الموظفين
أو العميل الخارجي للشركة
أي تحدي تشوفه قدامك
تعال وقول: هذه مشكلة موجودة تحتاج أن نحلها
وبعدها نوظف هذه المنهجيات لإيجاد هذه الحلول
إذا خلصتها أنت تضيف عليها بناء القصة
بناء القصة صحيح
أيش أهمية بناء القصة؟
بناء القصة أنا شوفها من أهم المراحل التي يحتاجها المبتكر
ليه؟ لأن أحيانًا لا يكفي أن تكون لديك فكرة جيدة
يحتاج أن تكون لديك المهارة
حتى تعرض هذه الفكرة الجيدة بطريقة مؤثرة
ولهذا أنا فعلًا أضيف عادة بناء القصة حول هذه الفكرة
الناس قد يبدون بالظاهر بأنهم منطقيين إلى أبعد حد
لكن الأبحاث العلمية تدل على أن الناس
في لحظة استعراض الخيارات هم منطقيون
لكن لحظة اتخاذ القرار هي لحظة عاطفية بامتياز
فأنت لا بد أن تبني مهما كان هذا الحل منطقي
لا بد أن تضيف إليه لمسة عاطفية
كيف سيؤثر هذا الحل على حياة الموظفين قبل العملاء؟
فتبني القصة المؤثرة
لأن القصة بإجماع كل الباحثين في هذا المجال
هي أفضل وسيلة للإقناع
ولهذا تجد القادة المؤثرين هم الذين يروون القصص
القصة إذا صُنعت بعناية واهتمام تؤثر في دماغ الإنسان
بمجرد استماعك لقصة تبدأ في الدماغ
تُفرز بعض الهرمونات منها «الدوبامين» وغيرها من الهرمونات
لتعطيك شعور بالارتياح
بل تعطيك شعور بالتعاطف مع الشخص اللي أمامك
وتجعله أقبل للشيء اللي بتطلبه في النهاية
لأني أقول في نهاية القصة لا بد أن يكون فيه طلب
قصة جميلة، بس أيش تبغى؟
توظّف القصة بعناصرها كلها
حتى تصل الى هذا الطلب في النهاية
وأنا جربت هذا عدة مرات
وهي فعلًا نافعة جدًّا جدًّا
ولهذا أدعو دائمًا المبتكرين
إلى الحرص على تعلم طريقة عرض الفكرة بطريقة القصة
حتى لا تذهب جهودهم هذه كلها سُدى
أنت ممكن تسوي كل هذا
والطبيعي فيه أنك ممكن تسويه عشرين مرة
والعشرين مرة تفشل
صحيح
فهذه حتى إلى أن تصل إلى صناعة قصة رائعة
الأصل فيها الفشل، صح؟
حتى بعد القصة الأصل فيها الفشل
إيه، فممكن تسوي تسعين قصة
وتطبق نفس طريقة التفكير وتضمن الأدوات نفسها، لكن قد تفشل
صحيح، وهذا لا يعيب الحل ولا صاحب الحل
ولهذا احنا دائمًا نقول: أن طريق الابتكار يحتاج إلى إيمان
حتى عندنا إذا جينا نقابل أشخاص
نقول: احنا لا نوظف إلا المؤمنين
المؤمنين بأن هذا الطريق طريق طويل وشاق
لأنك قد لا ترى النتائج مباشرة
قد تتعرض لحالات رفض كثيرة
ولهذا تجد حتى «توني فاضل» اللي قلت لك ابتكر الآيبود
اشتغل في شركات كبيرة وصنع أجهزة كثيرة
بل صنع أجهزة لـ«فليبس» يوم انتقل الى «فليبس» كلها فشلت
فيوم طلع من «فليبس» اشتغل على فكرة معينة
وراح عرضها ثمانين مرة، ورُفضت ثمانين مرة
لكن يوم راح لأبل لصناعة الآيبود
كان يقول كنت متأكد أنني في هذه المرة سأنجح
بعد سنوات طويلة من الفشل والمحاولة
وصنع أشياء خيالية
بل يقولون أنه صنع أسرع معالج في العالم وهو في الجامعة
هو كان ذكي، لكن هذا كله لم يساعده في أن يحقق نجاح كبير
لكن ستأتي اللحظة التي تحقق فيها النجاح الكبير
ولهذا لما كنا نتكلم عن توظيف المؤمنين
نريد أن نوظف ناس يؤمنون بأن هذا الطريق طويل وصعب وشاق
إذا كنت من أول حالة رفض أو حالتين ستنسحب
فهذا لا يناسبنا
هذا الطريق في الغالب الأصل فيه الرفض
احنا مثلًا في الابتكار المؤسسي نخدم القطاعات الأخرى
نحاول أن نساعدها حتى تبتكر
والقطاعات الأخرى في كثير من الأحيان
لديها ما لديها من المشكلات التي تجعل الابتكار آخر همها
فشلون تقدم نفسك على أنك جزء من الحل وليس جزء من المشكلة
وهذا يتطلب جهد ومحاولة وعلاقات
وصبر وإيمان ويقين حتى تصل بإذن الله
حتى «توني» مع الآيبود
ما قدمه كحل وقُبل في أبل مباشرةً
لأنه قدّم عشرات الحلول إلى أن أُختير آخر واحد
وفي الآيفون نفس الكلام
حتى مو بعد نجاحه في آيبود
كان الطريق ممهد أن خلاص أنت سويتها فتقدر
جلس العشرات إلى أن وُفق على آخر تصميم للمنتج
صحيح
وهذه من المفارقات الغريبة التي يظن الناس
أن «ستيف جوبز» هو من أتى بالآيفون
«ستيف جوبز» لم يأتي بالآيفون
هو الفريق الذي يعمل مع «ستيف جوبز»
بل عملوا عمل شاق لإقناعه بجدوى الآيفون
صحيح
وهذه يعطيك سبحان الله مثال على أن ليس ثمة إنسان كامل
كل البشر مبنيين على النقص
لكن يكمّل الناس بعضهم بعضًا
فهو كان شخص ملهم عنده رؤية
لكنه عنيد وعنده بعض المشاكل
كان عنده فريق مبتكر ومبدع
ومصمم على أن يتعاطى مع هذه الشخصية بمحاولات كثيرة
حتى يصل إلى ما يبتغي
وعارضهم في أشياء كثيرة حتى في فتح الـ«آيتونز» لمتجر التطبيقات
للناس من خارج أبل
أو عارضهم بأنه يعمل اتصال مع الـ«ويندوز»
وهذه كلها كان قرارات «ستيف جوبز» فيها خاطئة
والفريق الذي معه كان مصيب
ونقلت أبل من مكان إلى مكان مختلف تمامًا
بالحديث عن «جوبز» أيش الأدوار المثالية
اللي يكون فيها القائد محفز للإبداع؟
أهم شيء أن يفتح القائد المجال للناس
حتى يشاركوا أفكارهم وأراءهم
مرةً أخرى، قد يبدو هذا الكلام بديهي
لكن القادة أحيانًا بعضهم بشكل غير مباشر أو لا إرادي
لا يفتحوا المجال للناس أن يعارضوا آراءهم
لأن إذا لم يشعر الشخص اللي أمامك
أن بإمكانه أن يقترح ويعارض؛ سيصمت
فلا بد أنك تفتح لهم المجال
وأنا أحيانًا أقول: سياسة الأبواب المفتوحة لا تكفي
ما يكفي أنك تفتح بابك
لا بد أنك تهيئ المكان للناس حتى تأتي وتدخل
فأول شيء تعطيهم المجال والأريحية
تسأل الأسئلة الصعبة، الأسئلة التي تحفز التفكير لديهم
يقولون: السؤال أهم بكثير من الإجابة
السؤال يفتح مجالات كثيرة للبحث
قد تأخذك إلى آفاق بعيدة جدًّا
لكن الجواب هو نهاية القصة
فالقائد يحتاج إلى أن يسأل الأسئلة المهمة
التي تُلهم موظفيه وتجعلهم يبحثون
أيضًا يكافئهم على جهودهم وعلى محاولاتهم
يتقبّل الفشل ويحميهم في حالة النجاح والفشل
طبعًا أنا لا أعتبر نفسي قائد إبداعي
لكن دائمًا أحاول أن أكون قائد إبداعي
في بعض الأحيان بعض الموظفين يقول: ترى عادي؟
أقول: عادي، أكبر شيء ممكن يصير
أني أضطر أن أذهب إلى شخص معين وأقول آسف
عادي. لا بد أنك تجرب، تعطيهم مساحة للخطأ
القائد يحتاج إلى أن يعطي فريقه مساحة للخطأ
إذا شوفت الموظف يتردد إلى مكتبك عند كل قرار
فعلم أن ثمة مشكلة
إذا شوفت موظفك يدعوك إلى كل اجتماع
لا بد أن تعطيهم هذه المساحة أن يجربون ويختبرون
والقائد الإبداعي من وجهة نظري
لا بد أن يتمتع بمهارة السرد القصصي
لأن هذه المهارة تُلهم الآخرين، تُلهم الموظفين
حتى في وقت الشدائد
احنا نقول: إذا كنت في بيئة إبداعية، وصارت مصيبة
لا يصبح همنا أن نعرف من المسؤول
بقدر تركيزنا على حل هذه المشكلة
ثم نأخذ هذه القصة والتجربة ونصنع منها قصة ملهمة
تذكرنا في كل مرة أننا وقعنا في هذه المشكلة
واستطعنا كفريق أن نتجاوزها
ونستطيع أن نتجاوز مثيلاتها في كل مرة إن شاء الله
فيه اللي تقول عليها اللي هو المستكشف والبستاني والموجّه
لو تشرح لي وحدة وحدة
تصدق نسيت هذه بالضبط، لكن...
طيب مثل البستاني، المستكشف أحس أنه واضح
أن تسأل السؤال الصحيح
البستاني إيه
في المستكشف لعلك شرحتها قبل شوي
بس البستاني ودي أعرف
البستاني هو الذي يهيئ البيئة والمكان
يهيئ التربة والمكان
ويضع الأسمدة في الوقت المناسب في المكان المناسب
حتى يسمح للنباتات والزهور والثمار أن تنضج
فالبستاني من أحب الأدوار إلى قلبي
لأن هو الذي يهيئ لك المكان
نتمنى كل المدراء يكونوا بستانيين
إن شاء الله يارب
يمكن يهيئون جنة ويمكن يهيئون جحيم، يقدرون يختارون
صحيح
طيب الله يعطيك العافية
الله يعافيك
هيأت هذه الحلقة لتكون حلقة رائعة
جزاك الله خير
شكرًا جزيلًا لك
وشكرًا لكم، وشكرًا لأيمن الحمّادي معد ومنتج هذه الحلقة
شكرًا لوهاب موسى خلف الكاميرات
ومحمد الحسن في الهندسة الصوتية
وعبدالعزيز المزي في التسجيل الصوتي
ومحمد نور شمّت في التحرير
وعبدالمجيد العطاس في التلوين
وفي إدارة محتوى التواصل الاجتماعي نورة السبيعي
في إدارة التحرير أسيل با عبدالله
هذا فنجان أحد منتجات شركة ثمانية للنشر والتوزيع
ننشر كل الإنتاج بحب من مدينة الرياض
الأسبوع المقبل؛ ألقاكم
الله يعطيكم من العافية
يبغانا نبتكر آلية كيف وهاب يتحرك
أنا أشوفه، تراه مسكين والله
والله يطلع
المكان ضيق عليك، يبغى لكم بس نص متر
صدق والله
الله يعطيك العافية وهاب
فيبغى لي أتقمص
يبغى لك أنت يوم تجلس هناك على الكرسي
الله يجزاكم الخير
أيمن يجي هنا يتقمص الدور
عشان يعرف أيش المشاكل اللي يسويها
ترى هذا صدقًا مهم
يحتاج أن الشخص يضع نفسه في مكان الآخرين
الحلقة السابقة سجلتها مع الضيف «نايف»
كان يقول: الظاهر أنها «شلمبرجير»
فأول ما توظف هو توظف موارد بشرية
خلوه يروح في واحدة من الرقّات يشتغل
عشان تعرف الموظف اللي يتصل عليك يبغى شيء
من وين هو جالس يكلمك؟
يقول: تغيّرت نظرتي لكل شيء
هذه شلون نعززها عند الناس، في كل مكان
والله أنا جلست أحاول، مع أني أتفلسف وأتكلم كتير عن هذه الأمور
لكن ليس شرطًا أني أفضل شخص في هذه الأمور
ترى أنا أعاني حتى في تطبيق هذه الأشياء
التعاطف داخل البيت
شلون أضع نفسي مكان أم العيال؟
صدقًا هذا يأتيني دائمًا بين الحين والآخر
لما أشوفها تعبانة ومرهقة وكذا
وأظن أن أنا كمان تعبان ومرهق وهذا يكفي
لكن قد يكون تعبي وإرهاقي مختلف تمامًا
فشلون تضع نفسك مكانها؟
بل حتى مكان الأولاد
فإذا صار هذا أسلوب حياة؛ يساعدنا كثير
بل حتى عند القادة
القادة لسه الموضوع أصعب
يقولون: من أهم ميزات القادة أن عندهم التعاطف
شلون هذا القائد فعلًا يضع نفسه في مكان الموظفين؟
أنا أذكر واحدة من الأشياء
اللي أحاول أسويها مع موظفيني قبل لا يطلع إجازة
أني أرسل له رسالة على الواتس أب
أتمنى لك إجازة سعيدة، انبسط في إجازتك
رسالة بسيطة، لكني يا أخي كنت أفتقدها لسنوات
ما كان أحد يرسل لي مثل هذه الرسالة، وكنت أحتاجها
ما يصير المدير يشعر أن خروج الموظف عبء
بيطلع إجازة هذا بنبتلش
يا أخي هو كذا كذا طالع إجازة
خله يطلع و هو مبسوط، صحيح؟
فأن تضع نفسك مكان الآخرين
هذا شيء في غاية الأهمية
وهذا اللي أعطي التفكير التصميمي القوة
ولهذا هي واحدة من أنجح وأهم المنهجيات للابتكار في هذا الزمن
قد لا تكون هي الأفضل
لكن أهم عنصر في نجاح التفكير التصميمي هو البساطة والسهولة
«إم آي تي» عندهم منهجية رهيبة
لإيجاد حلول الإبداعية للمشكلات، لكنها معقدة
وفيه التفكير الابتكاري المنهجي، الأشجار وغيرها؛ معقدة
التفكير التصميمي نجحت لسهولتها وبساطتها
ضع نفسك مكان الآخرين
افهم، ولّد أفكار، اصنع نموذج، وجربه
وأعِد الكرة مرارًا وتكرارًا
حتى يمكن هذه ما ذكرتها، لكن مسألة مرحلة التجريب
المفروض أن تأخذ حوالي 60% من عمر المشروع، ليه؟
لأنك تعيد وتعيد
من خلال تجربتي في الشركات وكلامي مع الزملاء
واحدة من أكبر التحديات أنك تظل تعيد
احنا نجرب أول مرة وخلاص
لا، لا ظلّك تعيد وتعيد
وهذا ما يجعل مثل هذه الشركات «آيديو» وغيرها شركات مميزة
لأن عندهم هذا الفكر
أن أعرف أني بوصل
حتى سألت مرة واحد كان في أكاديمية ألمانية
اسمها معهد «هاس بلاتنر»
تقريبًا أكبر معهد للتفكير التصميمي في العالم
عندهم نموذج عمل ممتاز
حاولوا تطبقوه في مكانٍ ما إذا بيضبط
هم عندهم طلاب يجون يدرسون في المعهد
وعندهم شراكات مع الشركات ألمانية للتصنيع وغيرها
«مرسيدس» و«بي إم دبليو» «بورش» وغيرها
أيش يسوون؟
احنا قلنا في التفكير التصميمي
آخر شيء يكون عندهم مشروع عادةً
يطبقونه على مشكلة حقيقية
فياخذون المشكلة من هذه الشركات
ويدفعونهم مقابل إيجاد حلول إبداعية
للمشكلات هذه اللي تعاني منها هذه الشركة
ويعطون المشكلة للطلاب اللي دفعوا فلوس حتى يتعلموها
فيعملوا على هذا المشروع
فهو يأخذ من هنا ومن هنا
فيوجدوا حل، ويعطيه للشركات
فكنت أقول يا أخي، جميل نموذج العمل
ما قد شفت مثله، لكن خطير
أنت شلون تأخذ مشكلة من شركة مثل «مرسيدس»
وتعطيها لطلاب حتى عندهم مبتدئ ومتقدم
ما عندهم متوسط، غريبين شوي
شلون تعطيها لطلاب ربما المبتدئين أو حتى المتقدمين؟ يا أخي طلاب!
شوف دائمًا العميل عنده الحق أن يرفض الحل
لكن في 99% كان يأخذ الحل ويكون مبسوط فيه
قلت: شلون؟
قال: احنا نؤمن بالمنهجية
نؤمن أنك إذا اتبعت هذه الخطوات
توصل لحل طيب
فسبحان الله
أسباب الله
الله يعطيك العافية
جزاك الله خير